five four three two one
hello Jordan Peterson hello mr. Rogan
hey very spiffy today thank you sir if
this is a new look for you you've been
rocking these a lot of these big
gigantic what do you call those things
those concerts you guys are doing what
are you with speeches
well lectures discussions as I think of
them as yeah yes I'm discussing I mean
you might think it's kind of perverse to
be discussing with a three thousand
person audience but it's not because if
you pay attention to the audience
they're constantly and the individuals
in the audience they're constantly
providing feedback so it's a discussion
as far as I'm concerned feedback in
applause laughter sometimes they shout
things out too or a shuffling shuffling
yeah well really what you want if you're
on track if you're where you should be
then it's dead silent and everyone's
focused and listening and so if that's
not happening I mean you know there can
be laughter or that kind of thing but
generally speaking you don't want to
hear noise from the audience
so if you're if you're onner if you're
pursuing a complicated topic and you're
paying attention and I'm always looking
at individual people in the audience you
know when the first few rows because
that's all I can see because of the
lights I'm trying to make sure that
everyone's on track with the talk and
you know there's people gesture with
their face and they gesture with their
eyes and they shake their head and they
nod and there's lots of things to pick
up and if you're not speaking with notes
you can really pay attention to the
audience and then you know if you're in
the dialog and that's where everyone
wants to be yeah it's an interesting
thing you're doing because you have
experience in doing that with lectures
and colleges and universities but now
it's the general public and people just
pay to see it
and you fill up these huge gigantic
theaters I mean I've seen some of the
places that you guys are doing it you
and Sam just got done doing one in
Vancouver and huge places antutu that's
right yeah back-to-back and yeah so it
was about five hours of intense
discussion over two days and you know we
were supposed to talk for an hour each
night and then go to Q&A
but we asked the audience Brett
Weinstein who was moderating ask the
audience if they wanted to go to QA or
continue the discussion and you know
that the response from the crowd was
definitely continued the discussion and
so we ended up talking for about two and
a half hours each night and again it was
the audience is along for the ride
mm-hmm you know and they were good
discussions as far as I'm concerned you
know it was kind of marketed as a take
down in some sense Harris versus
Peterson right but the discussion itself
was an attempt on Sam's part and my part
to further our thinking about the topic
and to bring everyone along for the ride
you know for the journey so to speak
yeah well you guys had two podcasts that
you did over the phone so this these
were the first meetings that you guys
had in person yeah it was the first time
I'd met Sam he said the first one that
you two had was marred by this
discussion about what is truth yeah and
it was a Lex a strange sort of you got
stuck you guys got kind of stuck in that
first conversation but I felt like the
second one was much better yes you mean
both of you kind of recognized there
were some errors made in the first
podcast yeah we ordered in on a
definition and yeah let it go and so
that wasn't so good yeah and I wasn't in
tip-top shape for that first discussion
well over for the second one for that
matter
mmm but they've been getting each
discussion I've had with Sam has been
getting better so as far as I'm
concerned and I think he feels the same
way and I mean we're chart we're trying
to sort something out that's really
really difficult and it's the
relationship between facts and values
which is parallel to the relationship
between say objective truth and a
narrative or parallel to the distinction
between scientific fact and religious
truth all of those things sort of are
layered on top of each other and it's an
extraordinarily difficult topic and so
it's not surprising that it's taking all
of this discussion to even vaguely get
it straight it's been a central bone of
contention among philosophers for well
probably forever but certainly since the
time of David Hume several hundred years
well what are the more fascinating
things is coming out of the realm of
podcasting is these kind of discussions
these long-form
live discussions in front of enormous
groups of people where you go over very
complex issues it's a new thing I mean
and it's it's something that's greatly
received by the public which is really
interesting I'm yeah you guys are
selling out all over the place yeah well
one one one I've really been trying to
make sense of this a because I'm
thinking well what the hell is going on
why why am i selling out 3,000 person
auditoriums and then and then but not
just me obviously Sam is doing it and
you're doing something on a larger scale
but very similar with your long-form
podcasts and and and then there's this
whole rise of what Barry Weiss described
is the intellectual dark web that's
actually Eric Weinstein is coinage and
so there's a group of us that would be
sort of clumped together for reasons
that aren't obvious but I've been trying
to figure that out as I do these
lectures another thing I'm doing with
the lectures or the discussions is
trying to continually further the
development of my ideas I use the the
stage let's say as a as a opportunity in
real time to think and I've been
thinking well if you're surfing you
don't confuse yourself with the wave
right that's that's a real mistake you
might be on top of the wave but you're
not the wave and I think this long-form
discussion and the public hunger for
that is best conceptualized like that
there's a technological revolution it's
a deep one the technological revolution
is online video and audio immediately
accessible to everyone all over the
world and so what that's done is it turn
it's turned the spoken word into a tool
that has the same reach as the printed
word so it's a Gutenberg revolution in
the domain of video and audio and it
might be even deeper than the original
Gutenberg Revolution because it isn't
obvious how many people can read but
lots of people can listen and now it
turns out so I mean you got a little bit
of that with TV right and you got a
little bit of it written with radio but
there was bandwidth limitations that
were really stringent especially in TV
where you could get 30 seconds if you
were lucky and six minutes if you were
stellar to to elucidate a complicated
argument so you can't do that everything
gets compressed to it to a kind of
oversimplified entertainment but now all
of a sudden
we have this forum for long-form
discussion real long-form discussion and
turns out that everyone is way smarter
than we thought right we can have these
discussions publicly and there's a great
hunger for it and I see this parallel so
and this would be what would you call it
supporting evidence for this hypothesis
the same things happened in the
entertainment world because you know TV
made us think well we can handle the 20
minute sitcom or maybe we can handle it
an hour and a half made-for-tv movie but
then Netflix came along and HBO as well
with the bandwidth restrictions gone and
all of a sudden it turned out that no no
we can handle 40 hour complex
multi-layered narratives where the
character shift where the complexity
starts to reach the same complexity as
great literature and there's a massive
market for it and so it turns out that
we're smarter than our technology
revealed to us and I think those of us
who've been placed in this intellectual
dark web group you know there's some
things we have in common we more or less
have independent voices because we're
not beholden to any corporate masters
except peripherally and we've been
operating in this long-form space and
the technology has facilitated that and
so all of a sudden it turns out that
there's more to people than we thought
and thank God for that I'm I'm
struggling with I want to I don't want
to use the word hate there seems to be a
non acceptance or a resistance to the
idea that anything of quality could come
out of this group of people it's really
interesting to me and I'm wondering why
when I listen to you speak or Sam or
Eric or any these people Ben or Dave and
I hear very interesting points and I'm
like why are people resisting that these
are interesting points why are they
resisting this and I think there's a lot
of people that are beholden to
mainstream organizations whether it's
newspapers or magazines or television
shows that feel trapped I think they
feel trapped by this format that they're
stuck in it's a very limiting format and
it's a format that in my opinion is like
I mean it might as well be smoke signals
or ham radio or something
it's [ __ ] it's dumb you know this
this idea that you gonna go to
commercials every 15 minutes and you
know and in between you have 15 people
arguing I mean I watched a panel on CNN
once and I think we counted 10 people
that we're trying to talk during this
five-minute segment I'm like who what
genius thought that it would be a good
idea to get ten people struggling for
air time barking over each other no
one's saying anything that makes any
sense because everybody's talking over
and trying to stand out and trying to
say the most outrageous things and I'm
seeing like some of the resistance to
this when we spend I mean pretty far
you know from Sam and I lean more left
and Ben leans more right and you're what
you would call a classic liberal and
Eric's very difficult to define and
Brett is fiercely progressive I mean
these are Brett in particular is a very
left-wing guy but this desire to label
and to have this diminishing label is
like all right or you know right-wing or
fascist is it's very strange to me well
there's a couple of things going on I
think one of them is that the
technological transformation that I laid
out and then the other is that I do
believe that especially for the radical
leftist types the whole notion of free
speech among individuals is not only
anathema but also something that isn't
possible within their framework of
reference I've been trying to think this
through very carefully because you know
free speech in some sense has become
identified as a right-wing issue and I
thought well how the hell did that
happen and then I thought oh yes well if
you're radically left and you're playing
the identity politics game there's
actually no such thing as free speech
because you're only the mouthpiece of
your group whether you know it or not
so you don't get to talk as Jill Rogen
you get to talk is like Joe Rogan
patriarchal white guy and that's it and
your audiences aren't a reflection of
your own opinions as an individual but
they're an attempt on your part whether
you know it or not to justify your
position in the power hierarchy and so
everything right now and this is where
the technology and the death of the main
stream media and and this and this
political polarization all unite
everything is turned into a political
conversation in the in the mainstream
media and media and it has to be cast as
left versus right and if you're
criticizing the left then all of a
sudden you're right and right-wing and
it has to be about politics it's like
well it doesn't have to be a pulp
politics it could be about philosophy it
doesn't have to be cast in political
terms and and then it's also subject to
a form of well it's made more stupid
than it has to be by these terrible
bandwidth limitations like I mean I've
been on mainstream TV talk shows and
it's very strange experience because
you're definitely content you know
Marshall McLuhan said the medium is the
message right the medium shapes the
dialogue and it doesn't in great and
great in in a tremendous way powerful
way you go on a TV talk show and maybe
it's an hour long something like that
and there's five guests and you've got
your eight minutes something like that
and you have to be bright and chipper
and entertaining and intelligent and
sort of glitzy and it puts that facade
of momentary charisma on you and if you
don't play that out you actually fail
right because you can't start a
long-form discussion when you've got six
minutes and if you're trying to talk
about something that's that's deep and
difficult well you want to talk about it
because you've got the access then and
the opportunity but you've got your six
minutes you can't help but turn into
sort of a glitzy entertainer and so it
cheapens everything and then the other
thing that I think is happening is that
as the mainstream media television in
particular dies the the quality people
are starting to desert like rats leaving
a sinking ship I guess they're good rats
if they're quality people but and then
the the there's evermore enticement to
use clickbait journalism to attract a
diminishing portion of the remaining
audience you know it's like one of the
things that's happened so if you look at
the five major indices of violent crime
in the United States they've declined by
50 percent in 25 years
it's absolutely beyond comprehension
it's so good this includes violent gun
crime by the way and yet the reports of
violence and media have gone up and up
and up and
I think well what's going on it's like
well it's it's its clickbait it's the
it's the equivalent of clickbait and
then to turn everything into a polarized
political discussion takes no real
intellectual energy but it's also driven
by the death spiral of the classic media
I think and I think that's actually why
the polarization seems to be so acute
now some of it is genuine but some of it
is some of it is the consequence of this
underlying technological transformation
and the death throes of the smoke
signals fundamentally what you're
talking about when you're saying people
especially radical leftist have to
concede certain points whenever they
discuss things that this is so true and
so important because you see that play
out over and over again there's very
little variation from the official
narrative when they talk about important
subjects or controversial subjects and
whatever they are whether it's you know
transgender rights or whatever whatever
is in the news that's that's big and and
and you know that it's very popular
right now there's these these certain
things that you're not allowed to
deviate from and that that's an insanely
restrictive perspective and it whose
establishing these norms like who's a
step question man yeah who is well I I
blame I blame the universities in large
part for this the activists disappear
but that's only a partial answer because
the universities are also responding to
legislation like title 9 so and and so
and so they've been driven into they
explain title 9 for people title 9 title
9 originally was just a piece of
legislation that that ensured that women
would have equal access to sports events
and so forth at the universities that's
what it was designed for but it's become
this umbrella legislation that pushes
equality of outcome essentially across
every possible dimension in the
universities and it's been used as a
weapon by the radical left but you know
some of that's driven by legislative
necessity with what's happening what the
reason that I think this is coming from
the universities is because I don't
think that this could well there's all
these activist disciplines that are
essentially subsidized by too high
tuition fees and also by state funding
and they've produced an entire
sub structure of activists and those
activists are doing everything they can
to lay out the theoretical structure for
the radical left and that's a that's a
structure that involves there's
buzzwords right diversity is one but
that means diversity by race and
ethnicity and sexual preference for
example as if those have anything to do
with genuine diversity of ideon and they
don't and there's no evidence that they
do inclusivity I'm never even sure what
that means
equity which is a marker for our what
would you call it it's a code word in
some sense for equality of outcome which
is an absolutely deadly doctrine I think
of all the mistakes that the radical
left are making and the moderate left
for not calling them out on it the
equity doctrine is at the top of the
list and then there's other associated
things like white privilege that's a
good one and systemic bias and which is
a it's an absolute embarrassment from
the perspective of a reasonable academic
psychologist because psychological tests
have been used to prove that there's
this implicit bias that lurks everywhere
and the tests aren't reliable and valid
enough to make that claim that's even
the people who've made the test the
implicit association test have admitted
except for mahzarin banaji who's the
chairman of the department of psychology
at Harvard they've admitted that the
tests aren't reliable and valid enough
to be used for the purposes they're been
using for and there's also no evidence
at all that these unconscious buying
bias retraining seminars have any effect
whatsoever that's positive it's all
nonsense pushed by this ideological what
fulmination zuv the radical left is
there any benefit in having these
conversations talking about implicit
biases and recognizing that there's an
extreme pushback against racism or
sexism and all these different things
and that even though these things these
these these ideas that they're pushing
might not be tested and proven the idea
of putting it out there in the
mainstream that there's a shift in
consciousness in terms of like how
people will or won't accept racism or
sexism or homophobia or whatever else is
being discussed that maybe it's far left
but maybe it's moving the needle towards
where it needs to I think that well that
I think that happens I mean I certainly
believe that there's space and necessity
for a constant dialogue between the left
and the right this is also something
that I've been developing more
particularly during these lectures so so
I'm going to lay out a couple of
propositions so imagine that you have to
move forward in the world you have to do
things and the reason you have to do
things is because well if you just sit
there and don't do anything then you
suffer and die so that isn't an option
you have to move forward you have to
move forward towards valued things so
you have to have a value hierarchy it
has to be hierarchy because one thing
has to be more important than another or
you can't do anything right here you're
to split with your choices so you have
to do things you have to value you have
to value some things more than others
then you have to act out what you value
in the social environment because you're
a social creature and you're not going
to do things alone then as soon as you
start to act out things of value in the
social environment you inevitably
produce a hierarchy and the reason you
do that is because no matter what you're
acting out some people are way better at
it than others and it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if it's basketball or
hockey or plumbing or law it doesn't
matter as soon as there's something
valuable and you're doing it
collectively there's a hierarchy okay so
then what happens
well the hierarchy can get corrupt and
rigid and and then it stops rewarding
confidence and it starts rewarding
criminality and power and so there's
always the danger the hierarchy will
become corrupt the right-wingers say we
really need the hierarchies and we
should abide by them that's sort of the
motif of patriotism and and and and and
and and positive group identity and the
left wingers say yeah but wait a second
there's a problem here a your hierarchy
can get corrupt and might and be because
some people are way better at it than
others you're gonna produce a bunch of
desert dispossessed people at the bottom
and that's not only good not only not
good for the dispossessed people it
actually threatens the whole hierarchy
so you have to be careful you have to
attend to the widows and the children
let's say the widows and the orphans
okay and so now and then you now you can
think about that as an eternal problem
you can't do without hierarchies but and
that's the right wing claim in some
sense you can't do without hierarchies
and they're valuable
but they're also prone to corruption and
they dispossessed people okay so now
that's an internal problem the question
is what do you do about it and the
answer to that is there's no final
answer to the problem so what you have
to do is you have to have a left wing
and you have to have a right wing and
they have to talk all the time about
whether the hierarchy is healthy and
whether or not it's dispossessing to
many people and then the problem with
that is as that discussion can go too
far because the right wingers can say
hierarchy überall is right that that
that we've the state is correct and
everything's right and so that's the
right-wing totalitarian types and the
left can say we'll flatten everything so
there's no inequality and so both the
left and the right can go too far now
the problem is we don't we know how to
define I think one of the problems is we
know how to define when the right goes
too far I think we learned that after
World War two I think if you're making
claims of ethnic or racial superiority
you get to be put in a box and put off
the shelf right you're not in the dialog
anymore it's obvious that the left can
go too far even though they're necessary
participants in the discussion but we
don't know when - we don't know how to
define when they've gone too far no and
and and you might think well that's the
moderate leftists problem it's their
moral responsibility to dissociate
themselves from the radicals just as
it's the moral responsibility of
reasonable conservatives to dissociate
themselves from the Birch John Burton
and Ku Klux Klan types that's a very
important point but but the problem but
it isn't just the moderate left's
problem because even the people on the
right don't know what to point to when
they say no you've gone too far as a
leftist now I've tried to it's
complicated because I think it's it
might be more than one policy I think
the really deadly left this presumption
is equality of outcome I think as soon
as you start talking about equality of
outcome you should be put in the box and
put off the shelf that's the but but it
isn't obvious why like that doesn't
sound like you know white people overall
it doesn't have the same guttural punch
that the excess of the right has it's
right you're for equality of outcome why
is that bad well it's bad because when
you play it out in society and there's
endless evidence for this it's an
instantaneously murderous doctrine and
I think it's because it shifts so
quickly into a victim victimizer
narrative I've had a great opportunity
in the last month and a half I got asked
to write the preface to the 50th
anniversary edition of Solzhenitsyn's
Gulag Archipelago mm-hmm and so I've
been writing that and one of the things
Solzhenitsyn did which was one of the
things he one of the things that made
that book arguably the greatest work of
nonfiction of the 20th century I mean
it's in the top ten anyways was to point
out very clearly that the excesses of
the Russian Revolution started right
away it wasn't that Lenin was a pretty
good guy and then Stalin came in
corrupted everything was like Lenin was
not a pretty good guy the revolution got
bloody really fast and what seemed to
happen so imagine you started to divide
the world up into oppressor and
oppressed right and you're gonna do
something about the oppressors the
problem is is that you can define people
multiple ways this is the
intersectionality problem and almost
everybody can be defined in terms of
their group identity in some way that
makes them an oppressor so like if
you're a black man well you could argue
that you're oppressed because you're
black but what about the fact that
you're a man and so does that make you
an oppressor or someone who's oppressed
and the answer is as the revolution
progresses if there's any dimension
along which you can be categorized as
oppressor you end up dead and so that's
part of the pathology of the Equality of
oh me whether look you end up dead you
end up rounded up you ended up being put
into the oppressor camp right it's
slowly there's only so far you can go
with that right I mean you can't put all
men in the oppressor camp there'll be no
men left plays out what it is how it
plays I wouldn't look for equality of
outcome well it is how it played out in
the soviet union in china i mean in the
soviet union we don't know how many
people died the the the reasonable
estimates look like about 25 million
that's dead
that's not just that's not imprisoned
that isn't families destroyed that's
just dead and in my mouth was china it
might have approximated a hundred
million that's just internal repression
and so what what seems to happen as soon
as you decide that the hierarchy is
unfair because there are oppressors and
oppressed then you can go after the
oppressed
with moral virtue but the problem is is
that there's almost no limit to the
number of ways that you can categorize
someone as an oppressor that the
category just starts to expand like the
Communists killed all the Socialists
they killed all the religious people
they killed most of the students that
killed all the productive farmers and
they killed the productive farmers
because they owned land you know and
maybe a little house and a few cows you
know I mean to be a successful farmer in
Russia that at the turn of the 20th
century didn't mean you were rich right
it just meant you weren't starving it's
like they killed all those people
because they were oppressors because
they had more than someone else that's
how they defined it in order to get the
people to rally against it yes yes it
said yes and and that and the definition
kept slipping because well look look
even now it's like well let's say we
rally against the 1% you know and those
would be the money owners let's say it's
like okay who's in that group well
everybody in North America is in that
group worldwide yeah well who sets the
parameters it's thirty four
it's thirty four thousand dollars a year
sets you in the one percent worldwide
right right so does that make all of us
oppressors basically everybody who lives
above poverty in America is in the one
percent of the world right right and
also by historical standards yeah and so
the problem is the problem with the
oppressor oppressed narrative is that
you can multiply the oppressors
endlessly and there's no end to going
after the right and you as soon as you
make a definition you can move the
boundaries and then the next person is
the oppressor hmm and then you keep
going well and you also see the
interesting thing too is that and this
is complicated so I've been thinking
about this proclivity of the left to to
destroy members of the moderate left
it's like there's the game part of the
game is that's being played as far as I
can tell the ideologically pathological
game is I'm more virtuous than you now
look if you're on the on the radical
left and you say well you're more
virtuous than a right winger it's like
well who cares that's obvious because
the right wingers are you know
pathological so being more virtuous than
them that's not much of an attainment
but if I have my moderate leftist
compatriot standing right beside me and
he's pretty damn virtuous but I'm even
more virtuous than him then that's a
real that's a
real attainment on my part it's a moral
attainment with no effort on my part if
I can figure out some way of classifying
that previously virtuous person as an
oppressor along some dimension then all
of a sudden I get an increment my moral
virtue and that happened all the time in
these leftist revolutions run amok that
was just a constant feature so it's not
good it's not good why is it this is
something that's always puzzled me why
is it that the left is defined by
there's like certain there's certain
values and one of them is when you look
at the right you you automatically think
of racism potential racism at least
dislike for gay people homophobia
there's there's certain qualities that
are always attributed to conservatives
and then there's certain qualities or is
in that and these are social things and
that I'm not quite sure I understand
like why is it that the left is always
associated in support of gay rights the
left is always associated in support of
you know of all races and all genders
and I think it's the dispossessed issue
again so imagine okay imagine that we
make these hierarchies and they're
hierarchies that are devoted towards a
goal and that the sum total of all those
hierarchies is something like the
patriarchy even though I hate that word
and so whether I should use it I don't
like that word at all but but but that's
we're speaking within the confines of
that theory it's defining how you're
using it what do you mean by the
patriarchy well the patriarchy is is is
the sum total of all Western hierarchies
let's say it sorts the left
it's the radical leftist vision of the
sum total of all Western hierarchy it's
always male well that's the theory is
that it's male-dominated and you know
what has a patriarchy ism yeah yes well
and it's a funny thing because of course
there's lots of elements there's lots of
sub elements of the patriarchy that
aren't male-dominated so pretty
healthcare for example
universities the education system in
general there's lots of places where the
these these sub elements are female
dominated but so I don't know whether
defined as the patriarchy I'm do not
define healthcare oh it's a good
question Jo I don't know what
if if you have a sub-element of the
patriarchy that's dominated by women is
that still the patriarchy it's like the
structures still intact it's still
performing the same function well now
the women are running it well is that
the patriarchy and the answer to that is
well we're all vague about what the
definition is so we don't need to
address that issue well here's the
answers here's some clear ones right
like major corporations the vast
majority of CEOs are male yeah we think
of that as part of the patriarchy yeah
government you know never been a male
never been a female president vast
majority of Senators Congressmen etc
male yeah so I guess we could say well
the patriarchy is all those elements of
hierarchical structure that are still
dominated by men law enforcement
military male mostly male right but it's
a it's a peculiar definition right
because it means you have to you have to
fractionate the patriarchy into pieces
you can't you you can no longer talk
about it as a uniform structure if
you're gonna take out all those pieces
that are dominated by women say well
that's not the patriarchy but the thing
is is that the whole concept is so we
all define that it's that it bag our
description but so is you our though
right I mean it's well that's that's the
other thing that's the claim the other
claim is that all hierarchies are
predicated on power which is a claim
that's absolutely appalling it's like
plumbers they part of the hierarchy
hierarchy
you've got roaming bands of armed
aggressive tyrannical plumbers coming to
your door saying use our service or else
that's not how it works you go look when
you're going looking for a plumber you
go look for a massage therapist you look
or a surgeon for that matter or a lawyer
you go look for the person who's most
competent and one of the things the left
can't tolerate is the idea that
hierarchies are predicated in part even
on competence which they clearly are the
best predictors for success in Western
hierarchies are intelligence and
conscientiousness those are the best
psychological predictors of success they
only account for about a third of the
variation in success maybe a third is
probably about right so there's still
lots of room for randomness and and even
for systemic discrimination but the
notion that our our systems aren't
predicated in part on competence is
clearly wrong now you asked a question
about the left is like well why are the
left always on the side of
people who don't fit in let's say or
don't fit so easily and I think that is
a matter of the consequence of
hierarchical structures is that so
imagine in every hierarchy there are
some people who don't do very well in
any given hierarchy then imagine then
imagine across all the hierarchies that
there's a subset of people who are very
likely to not do well in any of them so
you might say well they're systemically
discriminated against the left would be
on their side because they're on the
side even temperamental II of the people
who are dispossessed and the thing about
that is that it's it's valid look we
need a we need a spokesperson
politically for the dispossessed that's
what the Democratic Party used to do
when they worked for the working class
is the working class needed a political
voice it's like okay that's the
Democrats well why did they need a
political voice well to to keep the
hierarchy from degenerating into rigid
tyranny it's part of the political
discussion but now the problem is is in
the purpose is the problem with the left
is that well what's the hierarchy it's a
tyrannical patriarchy it's like no it's
not it's partly corrupt like every
system but it's less corrupt than most
systems and there's a lot of elements of
it that are devoted towards
self-improvement self-monitoring you
have to be a little nuanced and subtle
about these sorts of things and you
can't throw the baby out with the
bathwater and the leftist rhetoric has
got so intense that the idea is and
people believe this while the world is
going to hell in a handbasket everything
is getting worse in all possible ways
and there's systemic racism everywhere
and it's utterly unfair and it should be
torn down and rebuilt it's like no it's
actually functioning unbelievably well
even though it still has its problems
you know and there's a big difference
between saying there's systemic racism
everywhere and the reason that there
isn't perfectly equal outcomes is
because of prejudice and saying no no
look the system is functioning now let's
say at 75 percent it's doing alright
it's got some problems including
systemic prejudice which hopefully will
work themselves out across time and
which show every bit of evidence of
doing so and so we don't need a radical
solution you know and and one of the
things I've started to do with my
Twitter account is to tweet out
good non naive news because one of the
things that's happening in the world and
there's been half a dozen books on this
or more written in the last five years
by credible people is that the
distribution of the idea of individual
sovereignty and property rights and and
free market economies etc out into the
rest of the world is making the
non-western world is making the
non-western world rich really really
really fast
so between 2000 and 2012 the rate of
absolute poverty in the world fell by
half half it was the fastest period of
economic development in human history
we beat the UN we beat the optimistic UN
target by three years staggering you
know the the rates of child mortality in
Africa are now lower than they were in
Europe in 1950 the fastest-growing
economies in the world are in
sub-saharan Africa many you know
millions of people millions of people a
month are getting access to this
incredible technology that's embodied in
cell phones right people have access to
fresh water like they've never had
access before the child that the kids or
kids are getting immunized at a rate
that's that's unfair that's that's
unprecedented and and yet we have this
idea that's become rampant in the West
that there's something ultimately
corrupt about the patriarchal tyranny
and that it has to be dismantled right
down to its core and a lot of that's
being taught by the activist disciplines
and universities and I just don't get it
it's not acceptable so they see these
hierarchies and their proposal to level
everything off and to take away the
insane power at the very top is equality
of outcome is unproven in terms of it's
never been it's never been done
successfully to a utopian right well I
and I also don't even think you can do
it in principle because if you accept
the proposition that the propositions
are laid out which is you have to pursue
things of value and if you pursue things
in a value in in a social space so you
do it cooperatively and competitively
you do it with other people then you're
gonna produce differential outcome
because people will be
pretty good at it yes it's like okay you
don't believe that it's like okay do you
listen to random selections of music
online or do you do what everyone else
does you go for that 1/10 of 1% of
songwriters and you'll it only listen to
them you only listen to the one you only
read the productions of 1/10 of 1% of
writers you only listen to the podcasts
of 1/10 of 1% of podcast broadcasters
right when you watch sports on TV you
only watch the athletic contributions of
1/10 of 1% of athletes so like where's
the Equality exactly where's that in
your life you people who are pushing for
equality of outcome you manifest that in
anything you do you don't you're
unbelievably selective just like
everyone else and the reason you're
selective is because you there are
things that are happening that need to
have an or that are entertaining and
interesting and you want the best in all
of those realms that's how it works and
there is a best that's the other thing
that's so painful and that that actually
is painful you know one here's a problem
of dispossession
a real problem one way to not do very
well in any hierarchy is to have a low
IQ and so IQ is normally distributed and
if you have an IQ of less than 85 it's
hard for you to read well enough to
follow instructions that's about 10% of
the population might even be higher than
that okay so given that lack how are you
going to compete and the answer is
you're not because low IQ is a good
predictor of poverty
now they spiral because you know if
you're if you if you're cognitively if
you're on in the if you're if you're
less cognitively gifted then
and you have children they're gonna be
in a less enriched environment these
things spiral but you still have the
essential problem that's the essential
problem of the dispossessed it's like
hierarchies or complex tools to attain
necessary goals but they dispossessed
people what do we do with the people
that they dispossessed the answer is we
don't know so we have to talk about it
constantly to figure out how to solve it
because it's an ongoing problem that
transforms and that's the reason that
political dialogue is necessary and then
the danger is is that the political
dialogue will polarize into the radical
left no hierarchies whatsoever or the
radical right our hierarchy is 100
percent right at all costs and so those
are the we have the eternal problem and
those are the two poles that we have to
negotiate between it's interesting
because the accusation has always been
that what the left is trying to do with
this equality of outcome thing is sort
of an infantile ization of the populace
right and the best example of that is
sports when you look at sports clearly
the best people win right the the
fastest runners win the race the the
people that have the best strategy win
the game the in fun in fact that's a
weird word in fun tile is a shinai never
get it right but of that is what we do
with children where you get
participation trophies and no one wins
you know when my daughter was three
years old she was in soccer and they
didn't keep score but everyone knew
everyone knew these kids scored and they
didn't at the end of the game they
didn't announce a winner
there was no catalyst you can't have a
soccer game without keeping score yes
not a soccer game anymore it's something
else but the score was kept of course he
just wasn't discussed of course it was
the strangest thing but this is to treat
these little kids because they couldn't
handle it you know you know she cried
when the other team scored I'm like
that's you it feels bad when they score
so it feels good when you score it's
very difficult to say that to a
three-year-old right so are we going to
run hills is she going to practice
drills so that she feels that good
feeling more and then there's a point
where that becomes too far there's a
point where you become an obsessive over
winner right and this is the people that
want to crush their enemies then you
become Conan the Barbarian this is this
is well our end of it is
what the left is terrified of right yeah
the idea of the left is the demure the
soft the the the people that are kinder
and gentler the idea of the right is the
Conqueror the people that you know their
work hard play hard
go kick-ass go America that kind of [ __ ]
and so these are the type of people that
are going to be crueler they're gonna do
what it takes to win and the the people
that you would consider that would like
equality of outcome are the people that
are trying to slow that down does this
make sense yes absolutely and I think
that's how it lays itself out
temperamentally it's psychological yeah
this is the motivation for all this yes
yes yes and it's well and the radical
left is is compassion going mad although
it's also envy let's not forget about
that
NZ well absolutely is one reason to
stand up for the dispossessed is because
you're empathetic you know and an
empathy is not an automatic good this is
something we make a big mistake about we
think well I'm feeling sorry for you
therefore I'm good it's like no I might
be feeling too sorry for you I might not
be demanding enough of you so and that's
the terrible devouring mother you know
from a psychoanalytic projection well
everything you do dear is okay it's like
no it's not right oh so so one of the
things that Jean Piaget the
developmental psychologists he was very
interested in figuring out a way out of
this and it's very much relevant to your
concept your your talk about about
athletics okay so so imagine this
because I this is also something that
points the way to a proper morality
which was actually something that Jean
Piaget was very concerned about he
wanted to he wanted to reconcile the
distinction between religion and science
that's actually what drove him even
though he was people don't know that he
was arguably the world's greatest
developmental psychologist so so here's
the idea you know how you tell your kid
to be a good sport you say don't it
doesn't matter whether you want to lose
it matters how you play the game okay so
I've been unpacking that in my lectures
because it's really really complicated
it's like you tell your kid that and
they look at you and they think
well what do you mean by that aren't I
supposed to try to win it's a soccer
game I'm trying I'm supposed to win and
you say well yeah you're supposed to win
but it doesn't matter whether you win or
lose it matters how you play the game
you know that that's right but you don't
know how to explain it to your kid you
say well you want to be a good sport
okay so imagine this this is how it
works and this is crucially important so
first of all life is not a game even a
game is not a game because a game is
most of the time a game is the beginning
of a series of games so let's say that
you're on a soccer team well there's
winning the game but the game isn't the
issue the game is the whole series of
games so maybe the game is winning the
championship and winning the
championship and winning a game are not
the same thing and the reason for that
is well maybe if you want to win a game
the best thing to do is to let your star
player make all the moves but if you
want to win a championship maybe the
best thing is for your star player to do
everything he or she possibly can to
develop all the other team members
that's a different strategy and the
reason it's different is because it
iterates across time okay so I'll tell
you a quick story so when my kid was
playing hockey when he was about 12 or
so he was in the championship game just
at a local arena you know and it was
really fun to watch the teams were
pretty equal which is something that you
want so that everybody can expand their
skills while they're playing and it was
like five seconds to to the end of the
game and the other team made a break way
and came down and the guy came down the
ice the score it was a beautiful goal
and it was 4-3 and that was the end of
it right and all my kids team there is
the kid who is the star and he was a
pretty good hockey player he came off
the ice and he was very annoyed about
what had happened he smashed his stick
on the cement and was complaining about
the refereeing and acting as if he'd
been robbed and his father came up and
instead of saying get your act together
kid that's no way to display yourself
after a loss he said oh yeah man you
were robbed that the referees didn't ref
right and and you played the best and
you should've won and I thought you
absolute son of a [ __ ] you're ruining
your son and then the question is why
cuz his son was the star and was trying
to win why was he ruining his son well
you're trying to train your son not to
win the game
you're trying to train your son to win
the championship and so that's a series
of games but then life isn't the
championship life is a whole bunch of
championships it's a whole sequence of
them and so what you're actually trying
to train your son to do is to be a
contender in the entire series and the
way you do that is by helping him
develop his character and the character
is actually the strategy that would
enable him to win the largest number of
games across the largest possible span
of time and one way you do that if
you're a kid is like well what do you
want to do with your kid you don't want
to teach him to win you want to teach
him to play well with others and that's
to be reciprocal so that means to try to
win but also to pay attention to to
developing the other people around him
and not to put winning the game above
everything at all times so then he's fun
to play with and this is absolutely
crucial you get you can you can help
your kid become fun to play with between
the ages of 2 and the age of 4 if your
kid is fun to play with then what
happens
kids line up to play with him and adults
line up to teach him and if kids line up
to play with him then they'll have
friends his whole life and he'll be
socialized and be invited to many games
some of which he'll win all of which
you'll be able to participate in and if
he's fun to play with in adults we'll
teach him things and then he wins at
life and so when you say to your kid it
doesn't matter whether you win or lose
matters how you play the game what
you're saying is don't forget kid that
what you're trying to do here is to do
well at life and you need to practice
the strategies that enable you to do
well at life well you're in any specific
game and you never want to compromise
your ability to do well at life for the
sake of winning a single game and
there's a deep ethic in that and it's
the ethic of reciprocity in games part
of the reason that we're so obsessed
with sports is because we like to see
that dramatized you know like the person
we really admire as an athlete isn't
only the person who wins we don't like
the narcissistic winners they're winners
and that's a plus but if they're
narcissistic they're not good team
players they're only out for themselves
then we think well you're a winner in
the narrow sense but your character is
suspect you're no role model even though
you're a winner and it's because
we're looking for something deeper we're
looking for that the manifestation of
character that allows you to win across
the set of possible games and that's a
real thing that's a real ethic it's a
fundamental ethic I think what you're
pointing out that's very important is
we're we're searching for the person
who's got it all nailed someone who
tries their hardest but is also honest
enough about the circumstances to not
cry foul when it's gone
the other person's way yeah well that's
part of resilience that's right like
you're not gonna win it you're not going
to you're not gonna score on every shot
right it doesn't mean you shouldn't take
the shots doesn't mean you shouldn't try
to to hit the goal but part of part of
being able to continue to take shots is
to have the strength of character to
tolerate the fact that that in that
instance you weren't on top it's more
trivial in games than it is in fights
and it's also the response is much more
negative to the from the fans if you
lose a fight and complain about it it is
it's ruthless there because they
understand that you've made a huge
character error yeah so why do you think
it's more important in fights than it is
in games why do you think it is because
the consequences are so grave because
you recognize that the high is much
higher and the lows are much lower to
lose a basketball game sucks but it's
nothing like losing a fight there's no
comparison it's not even so what do you
think it is the damages the fighter if
he complains about losing why is that a
mistake why do the fans respond so
negatively to that because they know
they know that you lost they know that
you're complaining for no reason and
you're not a hero
they want you to be better than them
they want you to be the person that has
the courage to step into a cage or a
ring or wherever you with whatever the
format is you're competing and to do
something that's extremely difficult and
when you do that they hold you to a
higher state right to lose with grace
yes and when you fall especially if you
were a champion that is one of the most
disappointing things ever when champion
complains right and and it is okay so
response is horrific from the audience
okay so that's a great example so let's
imagine what does the person who loses
something important with grace do and
the answer is fairly straightforward
accepts the defeat and thinks okay what
what is it that I have left to improve
that will decrease the possibility of a
similar defeat in the future yes right
soso so what he's doing is because the
great athlete and the great person is
not only someone who's exceptionally
skilled at what they do but who's trying
to expand their skills at all at all
times yes and the attempt to expand
their skills at all times is even more
important than the fact that they're
great to begin with because the
trajectory is so important more
important in particular to the audience
it's extremely important the audience
because you are the person who's
competing you are expecting them to live
out this life in a perfect way or in a
much more powerful way than you're
capable yes and so part of that is the
skill because they put in the practice
but part of that also is the willingness
to push the skill farther into new
domains of development with each action
and that's really what people like to
watch right they don't like to watch a
perfect athletic performance they like
to watch a perfect athletic performance
that's pushed into the domain of new
risk they want to see both at the same
time you're really good at what you do
and you're getting better okay so you
lose a match which is not any indication
that you're not good at what you do you
might not be as good as the person who
beat you but if you lose the match and
then whine what you've done is sacrifice
the higher order principle of constant
improvement of your own skills yes
because you should be analyzing the loss
and saying the reason I lost insofar as
it's relevant to this particular time
and place is the insufficiencies I
manifested that defeated me and I need
to track those insufficiencies so that I
can rectify them in the future and if
I'm blaming it on you or the referees or
the situation that I'm not taking
responsibility and I'm not pushing
myself forward and so then you also take
the meaning out of it like one of the
things I've been doing on my tour people
are criticizing me to some degree for
saying things to people that are obvious
well first of all it's not like I didn't
bloody well know they were obvious when
I wrote those rulings you were the rules
in my book for example stand up straight
with your shoulders back you know treat
yourself like you're someone responsible
for helping it's like I know perfectly
well that those can be read as cliches
the question is cliche let's say is
something that's so true that it's that
it's become that it's become it's widely
accepted by everyone well but we don't
know why it's true anymore and so it's
this issue that the issue that we're
talking about here or the issue of being
a good sport we need to figure out why
that's true and the reason that it's
true is that you're trying to push your
development farther than you've already
developed at every point in time and now
that's the proper that's the proper
moral attitude so
when you see an athletic performance
where someone is pushing themselves
beyond what they are you see someone
dramatizing the process of proper
adaptation it isn't the skill itself
it's the extension of the skill when you
see someone acting like a bad sport then
they're sacrificing that and so they're
sacrificing the higher for the lower and
no one likes that in the fights it's got
to be see the question is that's the
thing I can't quite figure out is why
that would be even exaggerated in a
fight situation and you said it's
because the stakes are so high
yeah the consequences of victory or
defeat they're just so much greater
there's your your health is on the line
it's one of the rare things that you do
where your health is on the line your
physical health right so there's more
extreme victories and more game defeats
and so the morality that's associated
with defeat is more extreme exactly
because there's more on the line and the
way people treat the champions it's it's
a it's a very different thing it's the
the respect and adulation that a
champion receives is it's the pinnacle
of sports in terms of the the love from
the audience when someone wins a great
fight it's there's nothing like it and
this is one of the reasons why these
people are willing to put their health
on the line because that high the high
of victory and it's not just a victory
it's a you know what what is that who
was it who said the victory is really
the victory over the lesser you it's a
victory it's always the victory is over
you've got to realize a guy like steep a
Miocic who defends is heavyweight title
this weekend in the UFC he is he's the
heavyweight champion the world but he's
not undefeated he lost in his career
he's lost a couple of times and he you
know as I'm sure he's lost wrestling
matches and sparring sessions in the gym
and all he's a product of improvement
right he's a product of discipline and
hard work and thinking and strategy and
constantly improving upon his skills and
so so in because of that he's the
baddest man on the planet so my in my
book rule for is this is 12 excuse me
this is from 12 rules for life rule 4 is
come
carry yourself to who you were yesterday
not to who someone else is today yes
because you need to be you need to have
a hierarchy of improvement you need to
be aiming something for something and
that means you're going to be lesser
than people who've always already
attained along that dimension yes and
that can give rise to envy so the
question is who should you defeat in the
final analysis and the answer is you
should defeat your former self
you should be constantly trying to do
that and you're the right control for
yourself to because you're the one who's
had all your advantages and
disadvantages and so if you want to
compete fairly with someone then you
should be competing with you and it is
the case and this is what we were
talking about - with regards to the self
improvement of the fighter is well if
you're improving yourself then what you
are doing is competing with your lesser
self and then you might also ask well
what is that lesser self and that lesser
self would be resentful and bitter and
and aggressive and vengeance seeking and
all of those things that go along with
having a negative moral character and
those are things that interfere with
your ability to progress as you move
forward through life so it's very
necessary to understand that this is why
you know I've been stressing this idea
of personal responsibilities like well
personal responsibility is to compete
with yourself is to be slightly better
than yourself the next day and it better
in some way that you can actually manage
and that's humility it's right like well
I'm a flawed person and I've got all my
problems could I be as good as person X
it's like not the right question the
right question is could you be slightly
better tomorrow than you're currently
flawed self and the answer to that is if
you have enough humility to set the bar
properly low then you could be better
tomorrow than you are today because what
you also have to do is you have to say
well here's all my flaws and my
insufficiencies and the best that
someone that flawed and insufficient
could do to improve and actually do it
is this and that's not worth going out
in the street and celebrating with
plaque arts you know it's like well this
is why I tell people to clean the room
it's not going to brag to someone that
you did that but someone is insufficient
as you might be able to manage it and
that means you actually are on the
pathway to self improvement and you're
transcending your former self and you
might say well what's the right way of
being in the world if there is such a
thing and it's not acting according to a
set of rules
it's attempting continually to transcend
the flawed thing that you currently are
and what's so interesting about that is
that the mean meaning in the meaning in
life is to be found in that pursuit so
I've been laying that out in these
discussions too because I said well the
the fundamental issue is that life is
tragic and difficult very tragic and
difficult for everyone and it's also
tainted by malevolence because no matter
how things are tragic and difficult but
there's always some stupid thing that
you could do or someone else could do
that could make it even worse than it
has to be
and so that's life and you need an
antidote to that because that can embed
or you constantcontact without just the
tragedy but the tragedy combined with
betrayal and malevolence that makes it
even worse especially if it's self
induced okay so you need something to
set against that so you don't get bitter
and resentful well what do you set
against that doing something worthwhile
by your own definition say you need some
reason to get the hell out of bed on a
terrible day because you've got
something good to do well what's the
best thing you can do transcend your
current wretched and miserable self
there's meaning to be found in that and
real respond that's that's a meaning
that's associated with responsibility
one of the things that I've been trying
to lay out clearly is that life is hard
it's tainted by malevolence and betrayal
that can make you bitter you need a
meaning to offset that where is the
meaning to be found not in rights not an
impulsive pleasure but in responsibility
you take responsibility for yourself so
you take care of yourself if you're good
at it you can you have some excess left
over to take care of your damn family if
you're good at both of those then you
have some excess left over to take care
of your community those are heavy
burdens you pick up the burdens you find
that's meaningful the best way to pick
up the burden is to continually improve
yourself and that's where the meaning is
to be found
and so that meaning is in the continual
self transcendence that's letting your
old self die and the new self be reborn
you did you watch when we were Kings
Elliott raesha yeah
god that's an amazing amazing amazing
movie right at the end of it so Ellie
defeats Frasier basically by letting him
defeat himself right because Frasier is
angry and he's got a chip on his
shoulder and he doesn't conduct the
fight properly so he exhausts himself
chasing Ellie and
is basically just trained himself to
take the damn blows right and to wear
Frasier out that's his plan then right
at the end of the movie he knocks
Frasier down and it's pretty much the
end of the fight but Frasier sort of
struggles to his feet you know he's just
getting up off the mat and Ally's got
his hand pulled back to just nail him
because he's completely laid open and he
puts his glove down and turns away
that's the end of the fight and Frasier
said and and this is true as far as I
know that that fight tamed him like
Frasier had a big chip on his shoulder
and it was a kind of a dreadful guy up
till that fight and afterwards he was
affable and he was he was civilized le
civilized him and so but that gesture
that Ellie made was that great gesture
because he could have flattened him
right and he had every reason to man he
got he got he got taken apart Ali took
punches like mad in that fight and then
in the final analysis when he had
Frazier down and he was struggling to
his feet he just let him go man
nobility of character right there
something impressive to behold
so when why are you defining people like
when you're saying this why are you
saying you're miserable wretched life
because there's a lot of people that
don't have miserable wretched lives that
also just want to improve like why does
it have to be the worst-case scenario in
order to because it has to work it has
to it has to work the theory has to work
in the worst case scenario okay that's
why so using the worst case scenario
isn't because you think that that
perhaps may alienate someone who doesn't
have the worst case scenario no no I
don't think so because well you know
what depends on how much time you have
to outline the ideas but you know what
what I because even if things are going
really well for you now there's going to
be a time in the future where things are
rough you know you're gonna be ill
family members going to be ill a dream
is going to fall apart you're going to
be you're going to be uncertain about
your employment status like the the
flood is coming right the apocalypse is
coming it's always the case in life and
you have to be prepared for it and the
question is how to prepare for it and
the answer to that is to find a way of
being that works even under the diarist
of circumstances that's the issue
and so you outline and I mean I am
pessimistic about this in my approach in
some sense because when I'm talking to
my audience isn't the same thing happens
and happened in my book
maps of meaning and in 12 rules for life
I'm laying out the worst case scenario
that's sort of like hell
it's things are going really badly for
you and that there's just chance
associated with that sometimes and you
and the people around you are doing
stupid things to make it worse it's like
okay what have you got under those
circumstances you've got the possibility
to slowly raise yourself out of the mire
you've got that the possibility to do
just what the fighter does when he's
defeated which is to say well regardless
of the circumstances that might have led
to my defeat like even if there were
errors on the part of the referee this
is no time to whine about it this is a
time to take stock of what I did wrong
so that I could improve it into the
future and that's the right attitude you
know in the Old Testament one of the
things that's really interesting about
the Old Testament stories is in the Old
Testament the Jews keep getting walloped
by God it's like they struggle up and
make an empire and then they just get
walloped and then it's all crushed in
there and they're they're out of it for
generations and then they struggle back
up and make an empire and then they get
demolished again and it happens over and
over and over and the the attitude of
the Old Testament Hebrews is we must
have made a mistake it's never to shake
their fist at the sky and curse fate
it's never that the presupposition is if
things aren't working out it's my fault
and that's a hell of a presupposition
and you might say well of course you
know what's that that underestimates the
degree to which there's systemic
oppression etc etc and and the and the
vagaries of fate it's like it doesn't
over underestimate it it's not the point
the point is your best strategic
position is how am i insufficient and
how can I rectify that that's what
you've got and the thing is you are
insufficient and you could rectify it
both of those are within your grasp if
you aim low enough one of the things why
do you see the that's another thing you
keep saying aim low enough have a low
enough bar why do you why do you mean
that well let's say you've got a kid and
you want the kid to improve you don't
set them a bar that's so high that it's
impossible for them to attain it you
take a look at the kid and you think
okay this kid's got this range of skill
here's a challenge we can throw at him
or her that exceeds their current level
of skill but gives them a
reasonable probability of success and so
like I'm saying it tongue-in-cheek to
some degree you know it's like but if
you're but I'm doing it as an aid to
humility it's like well I don't know how
to start improving my life someone might
say that and I would say well you're not
aiming low enough there's something you
could do that you are regarding is
trivial that that you could do that you
would do that would result in an actual
improvement but it's not a big enough
improvement for you so you won't lower
yourself enough to take the opportunity
incremental steps yes and so this is
also what is achieved through exercise
it's one of the most important well what
do you do when you go and lift weights
you don't go on like if you haven't
bench press before you don't put 400
pounds on the damn bar and drop the and
drop the bar through your skull I know
you think look when I started working
out when I was a kid I was I was wait
about a hundred and thirty pounds and I
was six foot one so thin kid and I
smoked a lot I wasn't in good shape I
wasn't in good physical shape and I went
to the gym and it was bloody
embarrassing you know when people would
come over and help me with the goddamn
weights here's how you're supposed to
use this you know it was humiliating and
maybe I was pressing 65 pounds or
something at that point you know but
what am I gonna do I'm gonna lift up a
hundred fifty pounds and injure myself
right off the bat no I had to go in
there and strip down and put my skinny
goddamn self in front of the mirror and
think son-of-a-bitch there's all these
monsters in the gym who've been lifting
weights for ten years and I'm struggling
to get 50 pounds off the bar tough luck
for me but I could lift 50 pounds and it
wasn't fair very long until I could lift
75 and well you know how it goes but and
I never injured myself when I was late
lifting and the reason for that was I
never pushed myself past where I knew I
could go and I pushed myself a lot you
know I gained 35 pounds of muscle in
about three years in University I kind
of had to quit because I was eating so
goddamn much I couldn't stand it
seething like six meals a day it was
just taking up too much time but there's
a humility in determining what it is
that the wretched creature that you are
can actually manage aim low and I don't
mean don't aim and I don't mean don't
aim up but you have to accept the fact
that you can set yourself a goal that
you can attain and there's not going to
be much glory in it to begin with
because if you're not in very good shape
the goal
Yuuka day could attain tomorrow isn't
very glorious but it's a hell of a lot
better than nothing and it beats the
hell out of bitterness and it's way
better than blaming someone else it's
way less dangerous and you could do it
and what's cool about it there's a
statement in the New Testament it's
called the Matthew principle and
economists use it to describe how the
economy in the world works to those who
have everything more will be given from
those who have nothing everything will
be taken it's like what's very
pessimistic in some sense because it
means that as you start to fail you fail
more and more rapidly but it also means
that as you start to succeed you succeed
more and more rapidly and so you take an
incremental step and well now you can
lift 55 pounds instead of 52 point 5
pounds you think well what the hell is
that it's like it's one step on a very
long journey and so it's it and it
starts to compound on you so a small
step today means puts you in a position
to take a slightly bigger step for the
next day and then that puts you in a
position to take a slightly bigger step
the next day and you do that for two or
three years man you're starting to
stride you know what I have so many
people coming up to me now this is one
of the things that's so insanely fun
about this tour which is so positive
it's it brings me to tears regularly
it's mind boggling because people come
up to me and this is happening wherever
I go now and they say they're very
polite when they come and talk to me you
know and they're always apologetic for
interrupting and so it's never it's
never narcissistic and it's never
annoying I'm really happy to see people
and they come up to me and they say well
I know you've heard this lots of times
before but I've really I've really been
putting my life together since I've been
watching your lectures then they tell me
a story about where they were in some
dark place too much alcohol too much
drugs not getting along with her father
not getting along with her mother not
having a vision for the life being
nihilistic playing too many video games
you know like being suicidal that that
happens a lot having post-traumatic
stress disorder sometimes as a
consequence of combat whatever little
slice of hell they were occupying they
say look I've been I've been listening
to your lectures and I've been
developing a vision for my life and I've
been trying to take responsibility and
I've been trying to tell the truth and
things are way better and so that's
absolutely perfect it's it's it's the
right way forward as far as I'm
concerned and those are
people who they took stock of themselves
they said I'm in a dark place
and I'm a dark person and here's some
things that this dark person in this
dark place could do little things that
they could actually do I'll clean up my
damn room I'll make my bed I've had I
don't know how many people have come and
told me it's so strange they said well I
started making my bed and that made all
the difference it's like well yeah you
decided a mop man and the first concrete
instantiation of that was that you made
your bed and you think well that's
nothing heroic it's like no but a man up
is heroic
that's something and then lowering
yourself to the point where you're not
above the mess in your room you know
you're not superordinate to that you
lower yourself so that you straighten up
you you're grateful for what you have
right in front of you and you take care
of it you put it in order it's like all
of a sudden things start to get better
and so wonderful to be doing this tour
because I see so that's what this tour
has been about for me it's not political
I never talked to people after the talks
for example I talked to about 150 people
tonight we never talked about anything
political it's always this I wasn't
doing very well
I'm putting my life together I'm getting
along better with my father I'm getting
along better with my wife I'm getting
along better with my kids I've got some
meaning in my life thanks a lot it's way
better it's like yes that's that's the
right thing it's very beneficial for
people and they need to hear that and
there's there's something that comes
along with that that's critical and what
that is is an honest assessment of
yourself an honesty that that type of
honesty honesty with yourself it's very
difficult for some people and they don't
have the tools for and they haven't been
explained how to do this why you sure
why you should yeah one of the things
that happens when you go through school
you're told what to do you're never told
how to think you never you're also told
that you're okay the way you are that's
self esteem yeah you're okay the way you
are it's like no you're not and this is
another thing that will you are and
you're not right you're okay as a human
look if you want to be a black belt in
jujitsu and you just started your first
class you're okay as you are you're a
human but in the goal you're not okay
that's a greater goal the incremental
improvement is
important you have to you have to
honestly assess your position and move
forward yeah well that's it your a
position yeah its trajectory yes right
and and when you say to someone you're
okay because of your position that's not
good enough because you have to say well
wait a second you need a trajectory and
maybe you're okay if you're okay in your
position and your trajectory but you
know the self-esteem movements and all
of that will accept yourself the way you
are it's like no because you need a
trajectory and one of the things that
that I think one of the reasons that
audiences are responding to what I've
been saying in my lectures and what I've
been writing about is that I don't tell
people that they're okay the way they
are now I say no no you could be way
more than you are and they're relieved
about that you see because if you're in
a dark and terrible place and someone
says you're okay the way you are then
you don't know what to do about that is
right no I'm not I'm having it all right
having a terrible time and I'm hopeless
you're okay the way you are well then
what what that's it that's it that's
where I am and what do you want to tell
a young person you're seventeen you're
okay the way you are it's like no you're
not
you got 60 years to be better and you
could be way better
you could be incomparably better across
multiple dimensions and in pursuing that
better that's where you'll find the
meaning in your life and that will give
you the antidote to the suffering the
way I always describe it to people as
there are disciplines that you can
pursue and those disciplines are a
vehicle for developing a human potential
and if you get better at these things
you can get better at anything and if
you figure out what it takes to become
better at whatever sport it is or
whatever art it is or whatever you're
pursuing the same principles you can
apply to the way you treat people you
can apply to the way you educate
yourself you can apply to way you keep
your body in shape all those things are
connected that's why you have to import
impose order people have asked me in my
book why I wrote it as an antidote to
chaos you know because well there isn't
anything technically wrong with chaos
chaos is a place of great potential
well the question is what's the proper
what's the proper balance between chaos
and order
chaos potential and order well the
answer is look when you're a kid you're
all potential it's chaotic potential it
can manifest itself in any number of
ways and you maybe you don't want to
give that up so you're like Peter Pan
you want to be a kid forever because you
don't want to give up
the potential and you look out in the
world and all you see are Captain Hook's
you know who've lost a hand who were
chased by death because that's the clock
in the crocodile it's already got a
taste of him terrified by death and he's
a tyrant well I don't want to grow up to
be that so I won't be disciplined at all
well that's no good because the way the
potential transforms itself into
actuality is through discipline and so
then you as you said this is the trick
though you have to pick a path of
discipline whether what path of
discipline you have to pick is a
different issue there could be a rule
the rule could be the rule might not be
follow this rule the rule might be you
have to follow some rules so it's a
matter rule and the meta rule is you
have to discipline yourself and the
issue is well how that's not really the
relevant question you can pick a
disciplinary path that's why I often
tell my clients especially young people
they say well I don't know what to do
it's like that's okay
nobody does go do something do the best
thing that you can think of put the best
plan you have into practice it's not
going to be perfect and it will change
along the way but it will change partly
because you become disciplined pursuing
the path and as you become disciplined
you become wiser and as you become wiser
you become able to formulate better and
better plans so you can start vaguely
and confused and develop a plan that's
not so great and you start to implement
it and then you you you accrue
incremental wisdom as you implement your
flawed plan and that enables you to fix
the plan and so that's part of that
process of incremental self-improvement
as well one of the more difficult
aspects of that is personal honesty like
being honest with yourself being honest
with yourself about what you're doing
self-assessment it's very difficult for
people they don't they're never there
never taught it it's not something
that's encouraged no one it's dismal
maybe imagine you only got 100 you only
have $100,000 to go buy a house and so
you go buy it you go look at this house
and it's like Jesus this house man it's
like it needs a lot of work it's like
well that's all you've got
why are you gonna pretend that the house
is OK the way it is we're gonna look for
where it's rotten and where the plumbing
doesn't work and where the stove doesn't
work you have to go and look and see
where everything needs to be fixed and
that's like that is harsh man but and
then in order to do that properly
someone has to have taught you it's look
you aren't your problems well you
are your most fundamentally that which
if it confronts its problems can solve
them and that's the hero myth in in a
nutshell by the way the hero is the
person who confronts horrible chaotic
potential and tames it and make
something of it right that's that that's
the fundamental human story but the
problem is is that you have to face what
you don't want to face in order to fix
it yeah and so you look at all the
things about yourself that need to be
burned off that need to be dispensed
with
and that man especially at the beginning
especially if you're screwed up that
maybe like 95% of you just has to go up
in flames and it's painful even some of
that stuff that you have to burn off
doesn't want to die and it'll scream in
agony while you're burning it off it's
not pleasant but if you know that you're
the thing that can transcend your
problems most fundamentally if you know
you're the thing that if it faces the
problems can transcend them then you
have the faith that would enable you to
take stock of who you are and you have
to do that in small steps because most
people don't have experience in
transcending their problems so they
really don't know what it even feels
like it seems like an alien concept it
seems like something other people can do
but if you do it incrementally you can
show yourself that you can do it I mean
it's one of the reasons why they have
belt systems and martial arts you start
off slow oh my god I got a stripe on my
white belt oh my god I'm a blue belt you
feel improvement yeah and for some
people it's the first real improvement
marked absolute improvement in their
life Yeah right well then that's an
interesting thing too because right
there you've got a bit of a measurement
system we have this system set up online
called the future authoring program and
we've implemented it because we've
tested it three times we implemented at
Mohawk College in Canada and we had
people write about their ideal future
and also to put in measurement
strategies it's like okay here's your
ideal future here's how are you gonna
break it into goals here's how you're
going to mark progress towards those
goals because you got to be playing a
fair game with yourself right because
when you make progress you want to
reward yourself so you have to identify
what the progress is and you have to
reward it the consequence we had people
write a future plan for only an hour
when they came for their school
orientation in the summer before going
to it's a it's a community college and
they dropped the dropout rate among you
men by 50% and his yeah no kidding
50% yeah and what that meant was to me
what that meant was just think about
that what that means is that these kids
have been educated for twelve years and
no one had ever sat them down and said
okay what the hell are you doing and why
and how are you gonna get like where do
you want to go why do you want to get
there how are you gonna get there
how are you gonna mark your progress
they've never walked them through that
exercise you walk people through that
exercise just to get them to do that
increases the probability that they'll
stay on track by 50% that's incredible
well it's one of the things I've always
complained about is that they know one
people teach you facts they don't teach
you how to approach life they don't
teach you how to think they don't teach
you how to confront why do the
insecurities and different traps that
your mind will set up for you yeah well
that's what partly what's so fun about
doing this lecture tour because that's
exactly what I'm talking to people about
one of the things I talk about is well
why do you think why bother thinking
it's like you think well that's obvious
it's like no actually it's not so
obvious it's like the issue that I
discussed with my students at university
a lot is well why write a good essay my
bother what to get the grade it's like
no that's not why and if you think that
well that's better than not thinking
that there's any reason for writing but
it's a bad reason why write well writing
is a form of thinking it's actually the
most demanding form of thinking I would
say there's other forms that are
demanding so how do you write a good
essay pick a topic that matters to you
because if you're not writing about
something that matters to you it's like
you're not living something that's
meaningful it's wrong you're not gonna
write a good essay cuz you're wrong
right to begin with it has to matter to
you well why does it matter what what
does it mean that it matters well it
means that it's gonna affect how you
make decisions in your life something
that matters affects how you make
decisions in your life well why does it
matter how you make decisions in your
life because if you make some stupid
decisions you're going to increase the
sum total of suffering a lot you're
going to do stupid things to yourself
you're going to do stupid things to
other people and you're not going to be
as good a person as you could be so not
only will you do stupid and terrible
things but
you won't have manifested the good in
the world that you could have manifested
so that's the lock so you write an essay
so that you can think and you think so
that you can live properly and so you're
right damn carefully you make sure that
every single bloody word is a word that
you want to use and you make sure the
phrases that you put the words in or as
solid as they can be and you make sure
the sentences are well constructed and
that they're organized into proper
paragraphs and the paragraphs are
sequenced and the content of the thing
matters and you put your soul into it
and you know when you've done that
because it's gripping when you write
it's meaningfully engaging and this is
another thing that I've been sharing
with my audiences meaning is actually an
instinct like you think okay so we
already decided that incremental
self-improvement is the proper route
okay so how do you know when you're
incrementally self improving properly
and the answer is it's deeply engaging
it's deeply meaningful and the reason
for that is you're actually adapted
neurologically to identify the pathway
of maximal incremental improvement that
was a discovery conceptually by a guy
named Vygotsky who is a rush of
neuropsychologist who coined the term
zone of proximal development you hear
now and then people say they're in the
zone that's the zone of proximal
development and that's that place that
you occupy when you're improving at the
rate that's optimal to you and your
sense of intrinsic meaning signifies
that that's how your bloody brain is
wired and so then you might say well
what's the antidote to the tragedy and
malevolence of life and the answer is to
put yourself in the zone of proximal
development because that's where the
maximal meaning is and that actually
does prepare you for life and so the
question why I think is well you think
before you act and you act to put
yourself in the zone of proximal
development and you do that to as an
antidote to the catastrophe of life well
that's the well that's the answer and
the thing that's cool about that and
then this is I think part of what I've
been telling people that sort of novel
is well where's the meaning the meaning
is in responsibility you know because
people avoid respond that's Peter Pan
again avoid responsibility it's just a
burden it's like no it's not it is a
burden but voluntarily hoisted it's the
place of maximal meaning and the more
responsibility you take the more meaning
you have and that's the antidote to the
catastrophe of life and and everybody
also knows this
because just look it's so simple when
are you sick of yourself well that's
when you're being useless and and
irresponsible for yourself and for your
family and for your community you're not
even taking care of yourself
well you can't sleep with a clean
conscience unless your psychopathic if
you're not taking care of yourself and
then wind can use window are you not
awake in the morning at 3:00 in the
morning tearing yourself apart with the
guilty conscience it's when you've done
something useful at least for you you
know and you can say oh well check one
on my side you say okay so fine you
adopt a little responsibility for
yourself and you can sleep with the
clean conscience what happens if you'd
opted full responsibility for yourself
and then for your family lots of the
people who are coming to talk to me say
now I've been really trying to put my
family together like I've made that a
goal I'm trying to heal my family and
bring it together and it's working so
here's a story I love this story man it
just killed me I was in LA at the
orpheum you know it's rough downtown in
LA it places around the Orpheum - and
Tammy and I my wife um because she's
traveling with me and is a big help by
the way um we were wandering around
downtown LA good morning after the talk
and we're walking down the street and
we're on streets we probably shouldn't
have been on but any in any case cuz
what the hell do we know being stupid
Canadians and so we were walking down
the street and this car pulled up beside
us this kid hopped out it's good-looking
Latino kid 20 21 something like that he
jumped over and he said he's all excited
he said are you dr. Peterson I said yeah
he said I'm really really happy to meet
you I've been watching your lectures for
like a year and a half and I've been
trying to put my life together and it's
really working I'm really doing way
better I really wanted to thank you and
so it's lovely when you're walking down
a kind of rough area and somebody pulls
up beside you and they jump out of the
car to tell you how much better their
life is that's a pretty good morning and
so but then that isn't all that happened
mm-hmm he ran back to his car he said
wait a minute wait a minute
he went back to his car and he got out
his dad and they came over together and
his dad was just smiling away like a
real smile you know and so was the kid
and they had their arms around each
other and they said look like we've
really been working on our relationship
for the last year and a half and it's
going just great we want to thank you
and their father said something like I'm
really happy that you got my son back to
me
it's like yes that's what this bloody
tour has been like it's great and
everybody that's coming to these talks
that's what they're trying to do you
know I got 3,000 people in each audience
and what they're trying to do is figure
out how can I take maximal
responsibility for my own life how can I
imbue it with the meaning that helps me
withstand tragedy and suffering how can
I be a better person
and wouldn't it be great if that was of
optimal benefit to my family and the
community you're getting very emotional
about this well it's something Joe Jesus
I've seen like a hundred and fifty
thousand people in the last two months
you know and this is what it's well
you'll have a chance to talk to Ruben
about this too this is what it's been
like it's so positive I can't believe it
and it's just one person after another
saying like look I was I was having a
rough time I'm really happy that I've
been encountering what you've been
talking about I've really been trying to
put things together and it's really
helping ya Ruben was pretty blown away
by it we had a long conversation about
it about he just feels like there's some
crazy movement going on that something's
changing in the world because of this
this new avenue of learning and
developing is opening up for these
people well well and I've been thinking
about that too because you know you like
I said at the beginning if you're
surfing you don't want to take
responsibility for the wave and so you
know I mean first of all a lot of what
I've been telling people are things that
I've gleaned from the clinical litter
and this psychological literature it's
not like I'm coming up with this of my
own accord
right I'm transmitting information that
I've learned from very very wise people
and so there's that but also we don't
want to underestimate the utility of the
technology right because we have this
long-form technology now and it's
enabling us to have this discussion and
so we can get deeper into things
publicly and socially then we were able
to before and I see this I see this as a
manifestation of that and and as and I'm
hoping too that maybe maybe what's
happening because we're gonna have a lot
of adaptation to do in the next 20 years
as things change so rapidly we can
hardly comprehend it and hopefully the
way we're going to be able to manage
that is to think and hopefully these
long form discussions will provide the
political or provide the public forum
for us to actually think to actually
engage at a deep enough level so we'll
be able to master the transformations
and I think that's possible and him
part of the reason that I wrote this
book and well part of the reason that
I'd be doing what I've been doing for
the last thirty years because I really
have believed since nineteen eighty five
something like that that the way out of
political polarization the way out of
the excesses of the right and the left
is through the individual I think the
West got that right the fundamental unit
of measurement is the individual and the
fundamental task of the individual is to
engage in this process of humble
self-improvement I believe that's the
case and that's where the meaning is and
that's where the responsibility is and I
think and I'm hoping that if enough
people in the West and then and then the
rest of the world for that matter but
we're very polarized in the West right
now if enough people take responsibility
for getting their individual life's
together then we'll get wise enough so
we won't let this process of political
polarization put us back to the same
places that we went so many times in the
20th century I don't see another
antidote for it it's not political it's
ethical this is the message that I
always hear from you and this is you as
a friend this is the you that I
understand but this is not how you're
commonly represented you are the most
misrepresented person I've ever met in
my life
I have never seen someone who has so
much positive that gets ignored and
where people are looking for any little
thing that they could possibly
misrepresent and switch up and change
and I'm kind of stunned by it I mean I
I'm really not sure what it is about you
that's so polarizing with all these
different people that are deciding that
you are some sexist transphobic evil
person that's this right-wing
all right the figure you know even to
the point where it's it's it's kind of
humorous to me sometimes when I read
some of these these takes on you what do
you think that's from like what what is
have you this is a new thing for you
you mean this only been the last few
years that you've gone from this
relatively unknown professor in a
university into
Anto to being this worldwide figure
where people you're obviously your
message is resonating with people in a
very huge way but the people that are
opposing you they're vehemently opposed
what do you think that is collectivist
don't like me collectivists what do you
mean by that
people who think the probably proper
unit of analysis in the world is a
political and B group oriented the
identity politics types don't like me at
all and they have every reason not to
because I'm not I'm not a fan of
identity politics
I think things that's why you're
misrepresented but mentally there's
other reasons I mean I came out against
this bill in Canada bill C 16 that that
hypothetically purported to do nothing
else but to increase the the domain of
Rights that were applied to transsexual
people but there was a there was plenty
more to that bill man let me tell you
and I read the policy dot the policies
that went along with it and it was a
compelled speech bill and so I opposed
it on the grounds that the politicians
are not supposed to leap out of their
proper domain and start to compel speech
it's not the same as forbidding hate
speech I'm I think hate speech should be
left alone personally for all sorts of
reasons but to compel the contents of
speech is a whole new thing it's never
been done before in the history of
British common law English common law
and it's actually the Supreme Court in
the 1940s in the u.s. said that that was
not to be allowed and so it was a major
transgression and they said well we're
doing it for all the right reasons it's
like no no you don't get it
you don't get to compel speech I don't
care what your reasons are and why
should I trust your damn reasons anyways
what makes you so st. like so that you
can violate this fundamental principle
and I should assume that you're doing it
for nothing but compassion and that
you're wise enough to manage that
properly it's like sorry no I read your
policies I see what you're up to I don't
like the collectivists I think they're
unbelievably dangerous and I have reason
to believe that so I think that when
push comes to shove if your unit of
analysis is the group and your worldview
is one group and its power claims
against all other groups that that
that's not acceptable it's it's
tribalism of the worst form and it lead
to nothing but mayhem and desire
and part of the reason you're doing it
isn't because your compassion it's
because you're envious and you don't
want to take responsibility for your own
life and I'm calling you on it and so
you don't like me so I must be an
alright figure I must be a Nazi saying
your house needs a lot of work man
there's a lot of rot in the in the
floorboards
the plumbing is leaking the water's
coming in you're not you're not the sage
and Saint you think you are there's so
much work you have to do on yourself
that it would damn near kill you to take
a look at it do everything you honestly
think that that's why people are
responding to you in a negative way that
they only have their own personal
problems that they're avoiding it can't
possibly be that you represent to them
something that is either cruel or
something that is not compassionate
about people and their differences and
their flaws and their their humanity
because I think it's certainly the case
that there the vision that's been
generated of me is yeah that's but
that's what I'm getting at oh yeah
there's that too but why is layers say
theirs well part of its the political
polarization you know at the moment
we're viewing almost everything that
happens in the world through a political
lens at least the journalists at least
first of all first of all I gotta make
this clear
first of all I've been treated well by
lots of journalists really well like the
best journalists in Canada have been on
my side since about two weeks after the
bill c16 thing erupted and those would
be the journalists that have an
independent voice and that are that that
have created their own following and
they're in a number of different media
places mostly in print okay and there's
a there's a coalition of newspapers in
Canada the post media group 200
newspapers they came out fully in
support of my stance on on Bill c60 and
so there's lots of times that I've been
treated properly by journalists there's
a small number of journalists very noisy
and a small number of activists very
well organized who've been on my case
right from the beginning and those are
people who are generally driven by a
very radical leftist progressive agenda
and I am not on their side I'm on their
side as individuals I'm on their side as
people who could struggle forward but
the collectivist vision it
deadly but you seem to be the poster boy
for this very simple characterization
like almost a caricature of what the the
the alt-right figurehead is it's it's to
me as a person who knows you it's very
strange to watch this take place and
then when they can find anything that
you say that could without further
explanation or definition be
misconstrued as appealing to this
definition of you like for instance when
all this when this what I guess they
call themselves in cells involuntary
celibates when all this stuff went down
this car drove his car into a group of
people it's horrible tragedy one of the
things that you talked about within
cells is that and this was a part of the
Rome what was it there's a New York
Times timepiece yeah you you said one of
the cures for this is enforced monogamy
people decided and you know I had never
heard that term before quite honestly
and that was like what the [ __ ] does
that mean
it's a psychological term and what it
means is enforced by culture that it is
a good value monogamy yeah because
polygamous societies tend to become
ultra violent yeah and that's been known
in the anthropological literature for a
hundred years and and certainly leftist
anthropologists were among those who
discovered it like she knew the
journalists knew perfectly well what I
meant by enforcement on me she was
stupid
it's a you use it as if everybody would
understand it because you're an
intellectual and because you're a
professor in the it was also two minutes
out of a two-day conversation you know
it's like so if that socially just
glanced oh well it's so fun that was
funny in some sense because my sense is
if you want a pillory someone you should
attribute to them views that someone
somewhere has had and the implication of
that part of the New York Times article
was that I wanted to you know take
nubile young women at the point of a gun
under state enforcement and deliver them
useless men it's like no one has ever
believed that so Trinity sounds like
yeah it's a really the optic
of that that statement are very bad but
the the question is why didn't why
wasn't there follow-up questions and if
there was follow-up questions to get you
to define what you mean by enforcement
not well there were they just didn't
make it into the piece that's a real
problem yeah it's a real problem that's
a real problem because that's that that
is it's so ridiculous because inaccurate
definition of who you are one of the
things I've said continually I'm and
this is on record in multiple places
it's like okay so you're a young man
mm-hmm
and all the women are rejecting you
who's got the problem it's not all the
women that's a bad road to go down if
all the women are rejecting you it's you
we both agree on this but why is enforce
monogamy the solution for people that
are involuntary celibates well it's the
solution to them it's the solution to
the relationship between men and women
fundamentally is monogamous social norm
men are unattractive if these were
suggestion to them but if these men are
unattractive to women I don't mean just
physically unattractive mean women
aren't seeking them as mates hmm they
need to become men yes they certainly do
so to this illusion that's the solution
absolutely and we both agree on this yes
what they need to do that in this
society where monogamy is the social
norm but isn't a social norm anyway well
that was partly my point although to the
degree that we deviate from that we tilt
towards a more violent society I was
making a very minor point I don't think
they're related quite honestly I no I
don't think that involuntary celibates I
don't think that having enforced
monogamy as a part of our cultural norm
is gonna help those people
it does how's it gonna help them well
because what happens is if a polygamous
society develops which is the
alternative then a small minority of men
get all the women that's what happened
okay I could see that's the only point
in which may fear Allah theoretical
world where polygamous societies exist
and mass and then you do have this
problem with this a small group of man
that are [ __ ] all the women but
that's not what we're talking and also
making the women unhappy right because
the women don't have any access to a
genuine intimate one-to-one relationship
over any long period of time which
doesn't work well nah it's the whole
and what's best women want that right
sure if you have children right but I
still don't think that that is why these
men are involuntary celibates and I
don't think it's the solution to that I
think the solution is that they need to
become attractive yes that is the
solution I don't think the two are
related well the only I was making a
minor point the minor point was that one
of the ways that societies around the
world have figured out that you keep
young male aggression under control is
by enforcing monogamous standards
because it gives everyone a chance in
some sense chance meaning it clears more
more women will be available for
one-on-one relationships rather than one
guy who is some you know whatever for
whatever reasons what you see well you
see this happening in universities where
women outnumber men so the man
hypothetically have more sexual
opportunity but that isn't what happens
what happens is that a small minority of
men have all the sexual opportunity a
fairly large minority of men don't the
women are on how because they can't find
a committed relationship it's bad for
most of the men and the men who have all
the sexual opportunity gets cynical but
isn't this in some ways against your
whole idea of equality of outcome
because you're you're talking about
equality of sexual outcome now if these
men James that's the dominant basketball
player that just kicks everyone's ass
this is the this this is a guy who's
succeeded at the highest level right
well there's gonna be people like that
sexually there's going to be people that
are better at finding mates and that
this is what they enjoy they enjoy
having many mates enjoy being yes but
but if this is what they enjoy if it's a
man who doesn't want a family and enjoys
dating multiple women why is that bad
well the I think the fundamental reason
it's bad is because it's bad in the long
run for children it's bad for children
if he chooses to have children
fundamental issue as far as I'm
concerned right and I think it's the
answer look to give the journalist
credit that is the point she was making
you know
apart from pillory me and and and and
caricature in my perspective that was
the point she was making well first of
all I'm not in favor of unbridled
hierarchies I've already said that you
know the proclivity of a hierarchy is
that all the spoils go to the person at
the top right and that can destabilize
the whole structure yes oh we have to
have a dialogue about how to rectify
that but how did you possibly rectify
that if one man is but like say if we've
got one six foot five beautiful man
who's got a perfect body and yet
brilliant and he just wants to date a
bunch of women yeah and all the rest of
the people are five foot one and they're
fat and they're lazy and like this guy's
gonna if this is the competition he's
going to win yep yep there's no way
around this and yet even decide to have
enforced monogamy where it becomes a
popular thing that women are gonna be
more drawn to him if he chooses to date
them they might decide I would rather
have him sometimes than never actually
what does happen but what is wrong with
that well what's wrong with it is that
it destabilized the society and it's bad
for children right you said that yeah
but that's what if they don't want to
have children but there's a lot of
people that don't want to have children
there's a lot of people that choose to
go their entire life without having
children there's men in their 30s some
of my friends have vasectomies they
don't want children
mm-hmm so why why would that help in any
way these involuntary celibates well I
think you tilt the society so that it
serves the interests of well that's a
good question to you but you see my
point I see your point no doubt about it
you're almost having you're almost
forcing and in an equality of outcome no
that would not was her point to him to
the degree that she had a point that was
her point now and but I but it's not who
doesn't run contrary to my opinions that
the issue of outcome has to be addressed
I already said there's needs to be a
reason for the left and the right and
then the problem with hierarchies is
they can get too steep and destabilize
everything that does happen that
particularly happens in the sexual
domain and there's plenty of
anthropological evidence for that but
you still might say well who cares
because the men who are who are winning
should be allowed to win and the women
should be allowed to choose
yes except that there's the problem of
children and so society steps in on
behalf of the children and you can say
well lots of people don't want to have
children
yes and that's truer now than it used to
be although many of those people end up
having children anyways you know the
guys who sit around all the time so that
doesn't circumvent the problem but the
issue here for me isn't the men or the
women it's the children if we're trying
to set up societies where the
probability that children will be raised
in something approximated an optimal
environment is optimized and that's
going to mean sacrifice of opportunity
and choice on the part of the dolt
is necessary I agree with you but I
think that what we're talking about
mirror's what we're talking about in
sports it mirrors what we're talking
about in business it's everything else
there's going to be people that are
better at all different aspects of life
talented in terms of like getting women
to like them yes that's true well that's
why I also look you see this right women
are high Pergamus which means they mate
up in a crew they meet across a knop
dominance hierarchies and so if you're a
male who's successful in a given
hierarchy the probability that you're
gonna have additional mating
opportunities is exceptionally high it's
an unbelievably good predictor of that
that
hypergamy is a very uncomfortable
discussion yes I'm certainly there's
plenty of discussions that's a big one
though it is the idea that it defines
women's sexual choices by the fact that
they want begger bigger better
well someone who's more more successful
and someone who's so higher on the
social ladder than what they're
accustomed to or what they yeah well
what women do is like mate choice is a
very difficult problem so how do you
solve it well here's how women solve it
throw the men in a ring let them compete
at whatever they're competing at assume
that the man who wins is the best man
marry him yes it's a brilliant solution
it's a market-oriented solution it's
actually the solution that appears to
have driven our evolutionary departure
from chimpanzees it's a biological
solution it's a logical solution which
shall cost what is the cost well the
cost is the cost is polygamy
and so we rein that in with enforced
monogamy and we do that in order to
provide stable stable circumstances for
children is polyamorous is a polyamorous
society just as unattainable as this
utopian Marxist yes yeah I think so
because it looks like this is another
point I was making that didn't get
covered in the in in the article or the
wrote about it somewhat extensively on
my blog is that society's tilt towards
monogamy across the world is human
Universal now that doesn't mean that
people don't have polygamists or
polyamorous tendencies because they
certainly do and it's certainly also the
case that one of the women ways that
women gerrymander this system is that
like the number of women children who
are in a say say you're married and you
have children with your husband but you
also have an affair so we have a child
by another man that's more common than
anyone suspected so part of the way we
way that women solve the problem that
you're just describing and I'm not
saying anything for this or against this
this is a purely factual biological
claim is they pick a monogamous marriage
and they cheat with high status guys now
you know obviously in the confines of
the marriage that's a terrible thing but
that's a very uncomfortable subject
though for women in particular
uncomfortable subject for everyone right
but it's a terrible subject they don't
like the idea that this is a common
thing that women choose a safe man
that is willing to be monogamous with
them and perhaps maybe they're above him
in a social class or in sexually and
then they'll cheat with someone who's
it's common but it's not the norm right
it's still the norm not to do that the
norm is fidelity right but but there's
plenty of exception this is enforced
monogamy culture is the norm is this
it's like okay so my son's getting
married in in September and so so let's
say he comes to me in a year and he says
hey Dad guess what I've had three
Affairs in the last year and they've all
been successful I haven't got caught
aren't ia good guy what am I gonna say
to that no what the hell are you doing
that's not what you're supposed to be
doing that's enforced monogamy
enforcement aagama meaning the
around you try to guide them in a way
that you think is gonna yes it's
harmonious family
yes it's built deep into the cultural
norms and if that starts to destabilize
then there's trouble and that doesn't
mean that it's not prone to all the
problems that you laid out look there
isn't a bigger problem than successful
reproduction it is the big problem and
all of the solutions that we've
generated for it are full of flaws like
here's an example the gender pay gap
okay there's no gender pay gap there's a
mother gap there's other reasons too but
women really take a hit when they become
mothers okay that's unfair fair enough
man what the hell are you gonna do about
it's not just that though right and this
is what also I'm starting to rub you
here but this is what's one of the
things that I wanted to bring up with
our kind of lost track of it the
misrepresentation of you mirrors the
misrepresentation of the gender pay gap
because it's a convenient
misrepresentation that upon further
inspection and understanding you realize
there is no gender pay gap the gender
pay gap when people discuss it that
don't understand and I've had these
conversations with really intelligent
people that just listen to what's in the
news or read some very quick article
talking about this problem that we have
and they assume that a man and a woman
are working the same job but the woman
is unfairly paid 79 cents to the man's
dollar that's not the case it's not as
close to the case of cases women choose
different professions that don't pay as
much they work less hours and they
oftentimes get married and have children
and because they have children they take
paternity leave remark less money that
we don't and they make less money
because that so is about ten reasons or
twenty reasons for the gender pay gap
right one of them being motherhood but
there's a whole slew of them but in
every dangerous jobs men work outside
men are more likely to move but it's
never discussed it's that's guys don't
like multivariate problems but it's not
just that it's a it's a willful
misrepresentation of a reality and I
think he's mirrors this woeful
misrepresentation of where you're where
you stand and I think these are all tied
in together with people want bad and
good they want a one in a zero they want
things to be very binary yeah they want
them to be binary in the way they
already understand it was every
to fit their ideological lens and things
are more complicated than that this is a
complex discussion that you're not going
to get in a five-minute segment on a
talk show
we're not gonna get this on a radio show
you're not gonna get this in an article
that gets edited by someone with the
biased opinion yeah and this is the
problem with mainstream media and this
is the problem with ideas period Warren
Farrell's book on he wrote a book called
Warren Farrell is the guy whose most
what would you call be most pilloried
for pointing out the real reasons for
the gender pay gap he wrote a book
called why men make more who D write it
for his daughters why because he wanted
to help provide it now obviously he was
doing it for public consumption as well
but one of the motivations was while men
do make more well why and if women want
to make more what could they learn from
the men who make more how to make more
and the answer is yes the question is
whether or not they'll do it and the
probably the probable answers most women
won't because how much you make isn't
the only hallmark of success in your
life you know it's like it's one measure
and it might be a measure that really
competitive men compete for and they do
and that's partly to provide access to X
to to to increase mating opportunities
because that's built into the structure
something we never talk about either
although we could so Warren wrote this
to lay out all the reasons that men make
more but it was so that his daughters at
least in part so the discharges could
figure out how to be socioeconomically
successful it's like yeah but that's not
the only hallmark how much socioeconomic
success are you willing to sacrifice to
spend time with your kids before they're
three years old right well the answer to
that shouldn't be none right because
what makes look we already know this for
for example once you make enough money
to keep the bill collectors at bay so
that's kind of lower upper working class
say something like even centrist working
class keep the bill collectors at bay
additional money doesn't improve your
quality of life other things do so maybe
it's a rational response when you're
like 30 see the irrational man here's
the irrational man maybe they drive the
world but they're the irrational men
more success is always better along this
unit dimensional axis of achievement
well Gordon Gekko greed is good well
there's a tiny percentage of men who are
hyper-competitive along those single
axis of competition and maybe they drive
most things they probably do but that
doesn't make them right
it also doesn't make them most people
and it doesn't make them happy
well happy is the whole different issue
right that's what they're out of it
because everyone is well you you are
though in in pursuit of success it's
implied that happiness goes with that
success otherwise why the [ __ ] you doing
it yeah well Dominus
domination power charisma prestige well
you apply it is success and Happiness or
they're inexorably connected in our
perception yeah well often a flawed
equation you know like what happens look
I worked in law firms with law firms for
a very long period of time and I worked
for lots of high-end women lots of them
and they were like they were usually
extremely attractive they were extremely
intelligent they were extremely driven
they were very very conscientious they
varied in how agreeable they were some
were disagreeable litigator types and
some were more agreeable they often had
a harder time in the law firms but the
law firms lose all their women in the
30s they all bail out at partner level a
lot of them well held Jesus it's it's
yeah it's a good percentage it's a huge
percentage and it isn't because the law
firms don't want them the law firms want
them because you can't find people like
that they're really rare especially if
there are also rain makers if they can
bring in money so the law firms Bend
themselves over backwards trying to keep
the women they can't keep them why well
the women decide that oh I'm working 18
hours a day flat out all the time seven
days a week
my husband makes a fair bit of money if
I made half as much money as I made we'd
still have plenty of money why am i
working 18 hours a day well that's not
the question the question is why would
anyone work 18 hours a day that's the
mystery and the answer is a small
minority of men are driven to do that
and so they'll do that no matter where
you put these guys that's what they do
yes
okay but that does that mean it's
correct I think there's something wrong
with these women they hit 30
they've hit partner they've hit the
pinnacle I mean they could keep going if
they wanted to but they've accomplished
their goal they've definitely shown
ma'am their bloody well in the game and
they wake up at 30 and they think oh
wait a minute I want to have a
relationship and also I want to have
some time to put into that I'd like to
have kids
and I'd actually like to see my kids
it's like that irrational this is
another thing that you and I are in
agreement on but when I see people talk
about the way you discuss women they
misrepresent what you're saying and
paint you in what I think wilfully paint
you they do it on purpose they paint you
as a misogynist I don't understand why I
don't understand if it is because they
disagree with you on things so this is a
convenient way to demonize your position
by demonizing you as a human being but
wow it's partly too because I've made
the case that there are differences
between men and women
yes but like why that isn't a feminist
case is beyond me
it's like no they're exactly the same no
they're not it's ridiculous it is and
it's ridiculous it's confusing
purposefully confuse it yeah and then
thing is the data are in so look and
people have accused me of pseudoscience
you know which I really think is quite
comical because the studies that I'm
reporting aren't who's accused you of
pseudos Oh God journalists journalists
of all stripes especially when I talk
about differences between men and women
it's like oh that's pseudoscience it's
like actually no it's not it's bloody
mainstream science both biology and
psychology but why do they like to do
that well because it seems to be there's
a reason that goes along with the
radical leftist agenda that if there are
that a world of equality of outcome
could not be achieved and that's the
desirable world if there are actually
differences between people actual
differences like that aren't just
socio-culturally constructed so that you
could gerrymander there's also something
as well if you're really power-mad you
want to believe that human beings are
infinitely malleable because then you
can mold them in whatever image you want
and if you say no they actually have a
character right there's something built
in then that interferes with the
totalitarian regime but here's what's
happened is like look we've got a good
personality model we've had it for about
forty years something like that the Big
Five model five dimensions of
personality and they were established
statistically a theoretically by
left-leaning psychologists okay and I'm
not saying that they're ideologically
contaminated but what I am saying is
there's no evidence whatsoever that
right-wing leaning psychologists
produced the big five because there are
no right leaning psychologists so enough
for that that isn't why the big five
came up okay so once you have a good
personality model you can say okay well
do men and women differ and the answer
is yeah it turns out they do there's
quite a few differences but the biggest
ones are women are more agreeable so
that's one of the traits agreeableness
and it's the compassion politeness
dimension and they're more prone to
negative emotion anxiety and emotional
pain and that mirrors a psychiatric
literature that shows worldwide that
women are more likely to be diagnosed
with depression and anxiety just like
men are more likely to be imprisoned for
antisocial behavior which is the
reflection of low agree oldest this is
true worldwide okay so there's no
evidence of any bias unless you say
everything's biased everywhere in the
world fine could be but we've also
controlled for that so now there are
personality differences between men and
women now the first thing we might point
out is they're not that big so if you
draw a random woman and a random man out
of the population and you had to bet on
who is most aggressive least agreeable
and you bet on the woman you'd be right
forty percent of the time which is
actually quite a lot you'd be right
quite a lot but if you take the one in a
hundred person who's most aggressive
least agreeable there's an overwhelming
probability that they'll be male because
the the differences get more extreme
athlete at the ends of the distribution
people don't understand the statistics
you can have two populations that are
quite similar and still have radically
dissimilar outcomes if only the extra
s'matter so like who are the most
powerful physical fighters in the world
men all of them what does that mean that
there are no women who can beat a man in
a fight no it also doesn't mean that
there are there's plenty of women who
are more aggressive than men but if you
take the most aggressive physically
powerful people they're all men all of
them because they're like one in a
thousand people or 1 in 10,000 people so
you can have walloping differences at
the extremes despite most similarity at
the middle people don't understand that
but then the next thing is ok well there
are differences between men and women
personality-wise apart from the
biological ones are those caused by
cultural differences hey turns out we
can answer that
how rank order countries by how
egalitarian their social policies are
does everyone agree yeah yeah the
Scandinavians are at the top everyone
agrees left right doesn't matter
everyone agrees it's like okay so you
stack up the cultures by how egalitarian
their social policies are and then you
look to see how big the differences are
between men and women up that hierarchy
of egalitarianism and if as the
societies become more egalitarian the
differences between men and women
disappear then it's socio-cultural that
isn't what happened what happened was is
that as the societies got more
egalitarian the differences between men
and women got bigger not smaller
it means the socio cultural construct
people and I'm talking to you socio
cultural construct people you're wrong
you're wrong you make the societies more
egalitarian men and women get more
different who makes the argument in
opposition to this although all the
social constructionist all the radical
left wingers and what are they uses fact
they don't have facts but then they
criticize the whole idea of facts then
they go after the whole idea of science
as a Western patriarchal construct
what's their motivation the motivation
is that if people are different than
equality of outcome isn't is neither
desirable nor achievable and why do they
want equality of outcome why is this so
that's a good question well part of it
is part of it is actual compassion
look round it's it's it's not good that
some that people lose and it's certainly
not good that some losers lose all the
time who wants that you happy when you
walk down the street and see homeless
people it's like hey look the
hierarchies working look at these
homeless people no one's happy about
that right right okay so the fact of
failure within a hierarchy of value is
painful and so to give the devil his due
you give the left its dude just like you
do the right it's like yeah it's painful
that hierarchies produced dispossession
bloody right
okay what's the cure get rid of the
hierarchy hey well wait a minute man you
get rid of the hierarchy you get rid of
the value structure you get rid of the
tools that allow us to generate absolute
wealth and stop people from starving
it's a catastrophe
okay so there's there's the problem you
have to have the hierarchy but then also
it isn't just compassion on the left its
envy
it's like okay if I'm so if I'm standing
for the dispossessed what makes me so
sure that I'm not just standing against
the successful and maybe that's because
I'm bitter and jealous and envious and
resentful and certainly it's highly
probable if you look at what happened in
the leftist societies that tried to
pursue utopia and you don't read envy
and resentment into that you're not you
don't know the history because that's
clearly the why else did they become
murderous this is the question it's like
it's clearly the case that the Soviet
Union for example was motivated by the
desire for equality of outcome as a
primary motivation what happened
25 million people were killed why why
what was it all compassion and love for
the dispossessed or was it absolutely
bitter resentment and hatred for anyone
who had any shred of success whatsoever
on any possible dimension of evaluation
so this compassion for people that
aren't doing well when utilized the
wrong way or when approach the wrong way
leads to attacking people that do well
so the danger of compassion
that's exactly well look what happens if
you get beat you think oh look at how
isn't it lovely that the mother grizzly
bear takes care of her cubs yeah it's
lovely man till you get between her and
her cubs then it's not so damn lovely
and that's the flip side of that
affiliative agreeableness it's like if
you if you're on my side you know if
you're the infant who's sheltering under
my wings it's like I'm I'm the absolute
epitome of maternal love and care but if
I've identified you as a predator you
better look the hell out and that's
playing out in our political landscape
at a very very rapid rate that's the
female side of totalitarianism as far as
I can tell the feminine side of
totalitarianism it's not just that it's
not just that agreeableness motivates
aggression because it certainly does
it's also that it's that the envious and
the resentful can use compassion as a as
a camouflage for their true intent which
is to tear down anyone who has more than
them
that's the why you notice like when
there's discussions about the 1% we
already talked about this well who's the
1% well it's it's I'm I'm
I'm in and I'm in the in the park in New
York demonstrating against Wall Street
down with the 1% it's like wait a second
you're in the 1% there are mr. protester
no no you don't understand
the rich are those who have more money
than me yes right that's the definition
who's rich someone who has more than me
not me it's like well why why isn't the
1% North America why not because it's
inconvenient
that's an inconvenient fact so that's
part of it but there's the the envy and
resentment this is that the real
pathological end of the full compassion
that motivates the radical left it's
like yeah you like the poor do you what
makes you think you just don't hate the
successful and that's a question it's
like because you're not perfect man
there's hatred in you and the
probability that it's more powerful than
love is pretty damn high so so look to
your own look to your own viewpoint
before you go out there and try to fix
the hierarchies of the world just
exactly what is that and it's worse like
look in the Russian Revolution for
example let's say just for the sake of
argument that the first rung of
revolutionaries were only driven by
compassion maybe they were they all got
killed they got killed by the people who
came after and they weren't so
interested in compassion at all they
were interested in ferreting out
everyone who had a modicum of success on
any dimension and and doing them in and
that happened in wave after bloody wave
they killed all the successful farmers
those were the kulaks they killed all of
them round them all up killed him raped
them stole other property sent the
remnants to Siberia froze them to death
ten years later six million Ukrainians
died because they couldn't raise crops
why do you think that people are so
opposed to discussing these things or to
challenging cultural norms because one
of the things that I've seen especially
in terms of the differences between men
and women this this reaction to some of
the things that you've said has been
very it's very strange to me it's very
strange that people aren't
recognising that these are unbalanced
approaches and that there's well some of
it's just complicated Joe it's like well
let's say there are differences between
men and women just for the sake of
argument the biggest differences seem to
be an interest by the way and so what's
going to happen is that if we let men
and women sort themselves out there
aren't going to be very many female
engineers and tektites and there's going
to be a lot of female nurses there's not
going to be many male nurses and health
care types there's not going to be very
many male elementary school teachers but
is this a gap well that's the question
who knows do we know I don't know well
the idea of having an equal society
where gender inequality is completely
knocked down gender pay gap is
non-existent yeah well that's a problem
because that's a vision wallet of
alcohol it's also it's yeah the equality
of outcome thing is a non-starter
whether it's okay with like if men and
women sort themselves into different
occupations which looks highly probable
I don't know if that's okay and then
it's also were like okay compared to to
what alternative right like you should
every elementary school teacher be
female should every psychologist be
female because that's what's happening
and the answer to that is well I don't
know but but there's another answer
which is well what do you propose as an
alternative to free choice that isn't
going to cause more trouble than free
choice because I would say well okay
let's say I'm a feminist
for the sake of argument all right so I
think well there are differences between
men and women there are actual
differences and so some of those are
biological some of them are are
strategic in some sense because women
pay a bigger price for reproduction and
so that's going to lead them to make
different choices
that's just rational based on by its
rationality based on biological
differences so it's like a second order
biological difference there's
differences in temperament and interest
they're going it's going to lead them to
make different choices is that a pro
feminist stance or an anti feminist
stance it's only anti-feminist if you
assume everyone has to be exactly the
same and the outcomes have to be exactly
the same if the if your goal is no leave
people the hell alone as much as
possible let them make their own
informed and free choices then you let
the differences manifest themselves in
the world and you take your you take
your knocks because of that the problem
with that is this narrative of equality
the equality of outcome you
so now and just a quality of human
beings well that's looking at people as
we're all equal what we're not it just
some people are either different things
were equal in terms of our rights or in
terms of the way we should treat each
other metaphysical e equal yes right but
err every other dimension were radically
unequal and there's pain in that that's
the process the problem that's the
problem is the pain in that is real the
only thing that's worse than the pain of
inequality is the pain of forced
equality and I'm not being fast on about
that it's like look I see the the IQ
issues that is the killer one for me
it's like look if you have an IQ of less
than 83 you can't be inducted into the
American military by law why because
there isn't a damn thing you can do that
isn't counterproductive despite the fact
that the army wants you because they
can't get enough manpower that's what
they decided it's like okay so yo you're
on the low end of the cognitive
distribution what are you gonna do not
much and it's gonna get worse is that
good it's not good it's horrible
do we know what to do about it no right
and we can't have equality of outcome
amongst people with lower than 83 IQs
right no one's that no one's advocating
for that no one's asking for that well
people say well the IQ tests aren't
valid it's like well yeah one of the
conversations that you have that I found
to be shocking and it started a trend of
misquoting and misrepresenting you was
you did an article an interview with
Vice and yeah they use a snippet of one
of the things you said and tried to
pretend that you had made these very
Curt statements and one of them like so
he was annoying so I got kind of Curt
and that was probably my fatigue error
makeup is that the one you talked yes
yes yes makeup and the way people dress
you know and yeah what I was trying to
draw first of all how was he annoying he
knew everything he knew everything well
it was just in his attitude you know it
was he was calm bulging you he wanted he
wanted this from the very beginning this
was him mm-hmm arms crossed right right
eyes up it's like like a I know more
than you and B you're probably that
reprehensible person that I've thought
about an aside job to reveal he was
signaling he's left-leaning
he was deciding that you what you were
doing was representing the patriarchy
you were representing male-dominant
structures that he was saying that are
the they're not correct yeah was yeah
but it wasn't even that it was
left-leaning I've talked a reasonable
left-leaning people it was built right
into his attitude and so it made me a
little test here than I might have been
which was my strategic error and you
know you asked earlier well why do I get
pilloried with some regularity and some
of it is probably my own inadequacy you
know it's it's it's not it isn't that
I've handled all the opportunities that
I've had perfectly you know and I can
get hot under the collar it's a mistake
it's a mistake because the right
approach in these situations is to use
minimal necessary force and to allow
myself to get irritated let's say even
minorly when I'm faced with someone
who's doing this is not productive
doesn't work well and so I really need
to keep that under control and when I do
keep it under control it works better
the makeup one was particularly annoying
to me because I think it's a valid
conversation it's an interesting
conversation I said and they didn't put
this in their initial cut I said I'm not
saying that women shouldn't be allowed
to wear makeup in the workplace I said
that explicitly well that was why people
were so angry when they saw the full
version of it I mean the full version
was released someone leaked it right
someone who felt like you were being
misrepresented and that the editing was
unjust decided to really kit and people
were absolutely furious yeah well I
think that I think the Vice people
actually released it but other people
took the full release and clipped it
with the class release and showed how it
was being misread was yeah but so okay
so the the makeup thing it's like all
right look here's the first of all I
make a mistake sometimes in treating
journalists like I would treat my
graduate students so when I'm having a
conversation with my students and we say
well here's a problem its intellectual
exercise a sexual sexual behave
how do we regulate what are the norms
around sexual behavior in the workplace
so that's the question it's a question
we don't know okay here's a bunch of
possibilities possible rules right no
flirting no hugging no eye contact for
more than five seconds that's Netflix
right no hugging that's amazing
damn right they have no eye contact for
more than five seconds that's holy [ __ ]
no hugging that was that real it's real
look what if you're having a
conversation with a woman who's your
boss and she's asking you questions
about things can you look down every
five seconds [ __ ] Christ is that
reassess it's real it's real it's so bad
that's such a terrible idea
yes yeah it's a terrible idea but
there's a lot of women that I'm friends
with that I've never had any sexual
interest at all and we look at each
other say is what you say but you're a
potential rapists manifestation yes
right yes you get the whole picture so
so if you have a discussion you say well
look what are the rules governing sexual
behavior in the workplace
okay can you come to work in a negligee
no how about boxers if you're a man no
ok so there's some out a short skirt
well that this is the thing that Devils
in the bloody details right yeah it's
like okay we you can't come to work
naked
you can't come to work in boxer shorts
you can come to work in a suit okay so
the line is somewhere between boxers and
suit where exactly is the line exactly
can a man wear shorts well you can't
help why can a woman wear a dress the
way that men in in professional
organizations the way that men solved
this problem was that everyone wore a
uniform and a uniform makes you uniform
that's why you wear it and the uniform
is the suit and it's it's a derivation
of a military of military garb and so
the idea was what we want to get rid of
excess diversity right right in clothing
wear your damn suit then we know you're
playing the game and we don't have to be
distracted by what you're wearing okay
so that's what man did okay so now women
come into the workspace it's like hmm
what do they do well there's business
professional dress right and there's
some rules around that but but what are
the rules exactly exactly and I was
thinking well we're worried about sexual
misbehavior in the workplace you can't
look at someone for more than five
seconds you can't give them a hug okay
what about makeup do we have a
discussion about makeup
oh well no we kind of a discussion about
that it's like well this makeup sexual
signaling it's like well if you're a if
you're an evolutionary biologist the
question is makeup sexual signaling
that's not even a question it's like
well obviously that's what it is that's
why that conversation was frustrating
because he was saying cuz they want to
do it they want to wear it they want to
look good well and maybe there's not
even me well that's right right that's
that's right what does that eat but let
me think well everyone knows what that
means what you all has to say that no he
has to say that because in his tribe you
have to communicate that way Oh women
wear makeup because they want to look
good but he's doing that because that's
his take or because he's trying to rile
you up what you're getting riled up
right now both well as a journalist it's
kind of his idea or his job to challenge
you in some way and it the very least
offered the devil's advocate opinion
sure explain yourself better why
shouldn't they wear makeup they just
want to look good you need to explain
yourself better why you saying he did it
was like Oh dr. Peterson it's obvious
what it means for them to look good like
everyone knows that do you think I don't
know it like perhaps like he was
intellectually sparring with you and he
was being aggressive about it I think he
felt I think he felt that I think he
felt that it was necessary to challenge
me that that was his role as a
journalist but fundamentally he was smug
he thought he came out the entire
conversation with an air of intellectual
condescension it was built right into
the discussion right from the beginning
and he never dropped it it's like well I
know what you're doing and I know what's
up and I know how to take you apart and
I know that whatever you're talking
about is just an attempt to defend your
original opinions
oh god about an hour something like that
how much did they use Oh in the clips
hardly any of it I don't even know a
couple of minutes so yeah yeah so your
tendency to get riled up can be
exploited yes of course and it's it's
it's the problem of deviating from the
doctrine of minimal necessary force like
the best times the best interactions
I've had with contentious journalists is
where I've absolutely kept my cool you
know but and like Kathy Newman yes
exactly what you're saying is well
that's what he was like yes like I know
who you are and I know you're covering
it up it's like yeah well it's these con
DS
concepts these are complex situations
when you find men and women who are
sexually attracted to each other and
they're working in confined environments
for long periods of time and they
essentially spend more time with the
people they work with and they do with
their lovers and their wives their
husbands and it's weird you know men and
women interacting with each other and
closed in boxes is weird
Brenden offices closed in box they were
all together and if they find each other
attractive and they're interacting with
each other socially especially if
there's any interaction that deviates
outside of the work discussion you also
don't want them to find each other
unattractive right looks like if you're
taking someone up for dinner on a
business dinner it's like even if it's
guys going out together let's say it's
not like they're working to find each
other unattractive and I don't mean
sexually there's you want to manifest
yourself as why enjoy each other yes you
do and you want to be charismatic and
you want to be witty and all of those
things and that's shades and especially
when you when you add assuming a
heterosexual environment you add a
heterosexual component to that the
borders become fuzzy and so I was
talking about border conditions yes well
we're gonna have a conversation about
this let's talk about the border
conditions oh no we can't do that it's
like the discussion you guys wanted why
do you continue and agree to have these
conversations that are gonna be edited
oh well that's a good question the Jim
Jefferies one was another one yeah Jim's
a friend of mine but I mean he gave you
a good question and you actually gave a
good answer you said actually I'm
probably wrong about yeah yeah and you
were talking about whether or not gay
people should whether someone should be
forced to bake a cake for cake for gay
people yeah I said forced to probably
not they said well what if they don't
want to get baked a cake for black
people yeah and he said well actually
probably it probably should be forced to
yeah well probably wrong yeah well I was
probably wrong in everything I did and
that in that part of the discussion
because I hadn't thought that issue
through enough to actually give a good
answer he didn't expect that issue
because this is not something you talk
about commonly no and it's it's actually
complicated right I mean obviously the
whole I won't serve you because you're
black thing is not good but then again
you have you also have the right to
choose who you're going to affiliate
with but
that's complicated because it's a
commercial circumstance and then if
you're making a cake is that the same as
serving or is that compelled speech it's
like oh my god these are border cases
that cause a lot of controversy I don't
mean serving black people obviously
that's not a border case but these cases
that caused a lot of controversy is
where two principles are at odds and it
isn't exactly clear where to draw the
line and I'm not happy with you know I'm
not happy with my answer to that but I
hadn't spent that like week it would
take to think through the issue and
really have a comprehensive perspective
you didn't expect that to be a subject
anyway no no what how long did you talk
to Jim for oh I think about 45 minutes
maybe an hour first Oh two minutes yeah
well my daughter has told me and and my
wife as well my son as well and these
discussions we've been thinking about
how to handle the media which is a very
complicated question and one hypothesis
being don't do interviews that will be
edited and I've thought about that and
and and and being thinking about it and
that might be the right answer it might
be the right answer going fooling it is
right and well it could it could easily
be although it's the only way you can't
be misrepresented just all the problems
that I've seen with you all of them come
from you being edited yes I mean there's
complex subjects that people would
disagree with you on but when you look
at complete mischaracterizations of your
point
these have been established because of
editing yes well I guess the only
counter-argument is this and I mean a
lot of these a lot of these
opportunities come I've had
opportunities that are coming at me a
rate at a rate that doesn't allow me to
think them through as much as I could
optimally but but then there's another
thing which is it isn't necessarily a
mistake to lay yourself open to attack
because sometimes it reveals the motives
of the attackers like that's what
happened in the Kathy Newman interview
no that could have gone really sideways
like I was lucky there to some degree
because she interviewed me for 40
minutes or whatever and something like
that and then they did chop it down to
seven minutes or three minutes and it
was exactly what you'd expect and that
is what I expected after
away from the interview I thought oh my
god they're just gonna chop this into
reprehensible segments and pillory me
but I walked away from it because there
was 50 other things to do but then it
was so funny because they did do that
and then they put up the whole interview
and the reason they put up the whole
interview was because they thought the
interview went fine it isn't that they
knew that that was gonna cause commotion
not at all not a bit
not a bit and I know this is for a fact
so they put up the whole interview and
and then well what happened was what was
actually happening revealed itself and
that was very very effective now that
having that happen meant that I had
exposed myself to substantial stress and
risk because that was stressful I mean
first of all there was the interview
second afterwards I thought oh my god
I'm gonna get pilloried for that then
they did release the cut then they
released the whole thing then there was
all this response to it and then then
the the Newman people who were
absolutely flabbergasted by the negative
response said Oh Peterson has unleashed
his army of trolls and poor Kathy had to
go into hiding it's like there's no
evidence of any credible threats they
said they called in the police but you
can do that without there being reason
you can just say that which is what they
said they played a victim narrative
instantly although one thing Kathy
Newman is not even though she might play
it at the behest of her employers is a
victim she's one of the most powerful
people in Britain she's no victim so to
play the victim card in a situation like
that is absolutely reprehensible but
that's what they did and then like a
dozen newspapers did it and said well
Peterson's trolls are attacking poor
Kathy and I thought oh now I'm really
screwed you don't own your fans well the
other people that are interested in the
things that you have to say that you
have control over them like you can give
them marching orders yes well and how
many million how many million people do
there have to be before they're not all
trolls yeah cuz that was the real issue
there it's like okay ten thousand people
commented on the video trolls
okay what about a hundred and fifty
thousand well what about ten million
well now if you look at the video which
is about ten million plus all the clips
it's like 50 million and the comments
the pro the comments that are critical
regards to Cathy Newman's conduct are
running about fifty to one so that's all
trolls is it I don't think so it's
preposterous the narratives preposterous
but you see that was that was a good
example of taking the taking the risk
and I'm not saying it's val justified
and i think that it's very very
stressful you know but you know you take
the good you take the bad along with the
good and maybe maybe it's time for me it
might be time for me just to disappear
to some degree altogether you know
worried about being overexposed oh
definitely
I've been worried about that for a long
time yeah and is there any benefit in
that is it any benefit in more exposure
are we talking about the same thing we
were talking about earlier with regards
to men working insane hours I mean have
you is your message out enough that you
don't have to do these ridiculous
interviews made instantly maybe me now
me well and I don't want to turn into a
parody of myself and all of that I mean
I think and I am trying to handle listen
I've got people who are advising me
we're trying to figure it out I think
that this tour is a good thing yes and
but that's that's very controlled I
think well it's also completely unedited
yes exactly it is in long-form
conversations yes and I think that
coming on your podcast and talking to
Ruben on his shows and so forth I think
that's good the the interaction with the
journalists I'm certainly not taking
anywhere near the number of
opportunities that I have in front of me
right we are trying to be very careful
in picking and choosing but that doesn't
always go well and it's like it could be
that it could be that I shouldn't do
anything that is edited at all that's
certainly possible so well this is the
problem you speak in these you speak in
these long-form podcasts and interviews
and you get a chance to extrapolate and
unpack some pretty complicated issues
and compare them to other complicated
issues and try to find meaning and
middle ground and and try to try to
illuminate certain positions when you
expose yourself to editing you you
expose yourself to someone
idea of what the narrative should be and
how to frame your positions in it in and
dishonest way yeah and you're seeing it
time and time again when it exposes the
problem with medium look I went to the
Aspen ideas festival last week which is
a whole story in and of itself but I was
interviewed there by a journalist from
the Atlantic Monthly and it was a
relatively long form interview I think
we talked for 40 minutes something like
that and it's going to be edited
now I trusted her I trust her now
whether that'll be well how that will
play out in the final edit I don't know
because she won't be the only one making
the decision right well the question is
should have I done it well look it was
the Aspen ideas festival it's a
different audience it's left-leaning
I thought well maybe I'll go talk to a
left-leaning audience people are always
criticizing me for not doing that I
usually don't do it because I don't get
invited but so I went and talked to them
it's like and Barry Weiss interviewed me
in front of the Aspen ideas festival and
that was long-form uncut and put on the
web and so maybe that was useful the
Atlantic thing well it might be good
we'll see it does expose me to the risk
though because it'll be edited so and it
was it wise to do it
look I've been fortunate so far despite
the fact that I've been taken out of
context at times and fairly significant
proportion of times but not the
overwhelming majority of times the net
consequence of all of that has been to
engage more and more people in a complex
dialogue as far as I can tell so that's
the good that's the good it doesn't mean
the strategy that I've implemented so
far is the only strategy that will work
into the future we can also clearly
establish it you didn't planning this to
happen this this whole thing that
happened from you opposing that bill and
then going to where you are how many
years later now two years that's [ __ ]
crazy yeah I mean you think about the
transformation of your life and your
your public image
I mean it's unprecedented I don't I
can't think of a single public
intellectual that has gone from being a
universal University professor to being
essentially a household name I mean you
get brought up with at least my circle
of friends all the time and people that
I run into all the time I can't tell you
how many people have run into after
comedy shows or in an airport that
talked to me about you so this is a
mainstream thing and yeah well so that
cannot there's no precedent no well it's
partly you know that's also part of the
consequence of this technology he's like
yes no like in 2013 I thought huh wonder
what'll happen if I put my lectures up
on YouTube
it's like beware man and that's what I
thought when I made Bill c16 videos I
got up at like 2:00 in the morning I
thought this is bloody well driving me
crazy
that damn University is going to force
unconscious bias retraining which is not
a validated process by any stretch of
the imagination
on its employees and I work for the
University and I'm a psychologist so
like what is the what's why they doing
that why would they do that they'd do
that to silence people that are
protesting are they doing that because
they want to enforce a certain type of
behavior why do I think there's two
reasons I think that there's some
genuine concern for the dispossessed and
then there's some hatred for the
successful and some envy and some
resentment it's like everything that
people do it's calm
you know but the pathology is well that
that the HR types for example at the
university think it's okay for them to
retrain other people about their
hypothetical views on the off chance
that they might be racist and and
forcing them to admit that they're
racist by making them agree to
participate in the training I don't
think that and but for me that wasn't
even the the issue although it was an
issue the issue is we can't measure
unconscious bias reliably and validly
I'm a psychologist in a research
psychologist I know the literature
that's a misuse of it it's a misuse of
it and the damn University was doing it
they were hiring consultants who didn't
know what the hell they were talking
about let me ask you this if they are
this is a universities yes this is a
establishment for higher learning how
can they possibly act on something when
there's no clear evidence that it's real
that it works that it's effective and
they're doing it just to make people
happy or just to make themselves happy
or just to reinforce an idea that they
want to be true that's the thing that's
the thing it's part of for me it was
part of the hegemony of the radical left
it's like no no you're you're not going
to do that at the University I work out
without me telling people that there's
no warrant for that from the
psychological community so anyways I got
up at 2:00 in the morning and made these
videos I thought well let's see what
happens if I make these videos it's like
well this is back to the technology
issue it's like I didn't know what
YouTube was when I put my videos on it
you didn't know what YouTube was well
you know what I no one knows what
YouTube is how did the thing well look
at what happened to you you have a
million billion and a half downloads a
year it's like you're definitely riding
a giant wave like what have you
predicted this 15 years ago no so so you
know you're in the right place and the
right time and you're a very interesting
interviewer because well especially for
long-form because you're very very
curious but also very very tough like
it's interesting watching you because if
you don't understand something you will
go after the person and you're not doing
it in a vindictive way but you're quite
a formidable interviewer and and I've
been trying to figure out why you're so
successful and like you're a lot smarter
than anyone might think which is quite
interesting so you're a weird
combination because you know your
persona doesn't shout intellectual but
you're damn smart and you're tough as a
bloody boot and you ask really
provocative questions and not because
you're provocative and so your
personality in this long form seem to
suit each other really well you're also
really good at pursuing things you don't
understand instead of assuming that you
know what you're talking about so you
take the listeners on a journey right
it's an exploratory journey but
fundamentally what's propelled you to
superstardom in some sense is not just
your ability which is non-trivial but
the fact that you're on this giant
technological wave and you're one of the
first adopters and I'm in the same
situation we're first adopters of a
technology that's as revolutionary as
the Gutenberg printing press and so
that's all unfolding in real time it's
like look at what's happening yeah well
the spoken word is now as powerful as
the written word that's never happened
before in human history and we're on the
cutting edge of that for better or worse
that's a very good way to put it the
spoken word is just power yeah and maybe
even more so why is it so accessible to
people that don't have the time to read
well or stuck in traffic you know or or
and here's another possibility maybe ten
times as many people can listen to
complex information as can read complex
information in terms of their ability to
process it sure could easily we don't
know maybe it's maybe it's the same it's
certainly easier to listen to a book on
tape for me than it is to read a book
yeah well so for us so the question is
for how many people is that true and I
would say it might be true for them for
the majority of people and then people
are doing hybrids you know so because
you can sync your book with audible
right so they'll read when they have the
time but then when they have found time
which is also a major component of this
that that's the time when you're driving
or the time when you're doing dishes is
now all of a sudden you can educate
yourself during that found time this is
a big revolution and the band blowing
out the bandwidth makes a huge
difference because while we talked about
that at the beginning looks like people
are more intelligent than we thought and
you and I are both and the rest of this
intellectual dark web that's kind of
what unites us say is everybody has an
independent platform virtually everybody
they have an idiosyncratic viewpoint
they're interested in having discussions
and pursuing for the furtherance of
their knowledge even though they might
have a priori ideological commit
Sam doesn't I suppose I do and and Ben
Shapiro certainly does but they're still
interested in having the discussion but
more importantly they're capitalizing on
the long form and and the fact that
that's possible is a reflection of this
technological transformation and the
technological transfer information might
be utterly profound it looks like it and
so that's you know I've been trying to
sort this out because I keep thinking
why the hell are these people coming to
listen to what I'm saying it's like well
I'm a guru you know I'm a sage it's
something like that it's like don't be
thinking that first think if there's
situational determinants first take your
damn personality out of it okay what's
going on oh yes this is all fostered by
YouTube and fostered by podcasts what's
so new about that
no bandwidth restrictions no barrier to
entrance possibility of dialog because
people cut up the YouTube videos into
chunks and make their own comments on it
it's a whole new communication
technology also a lack of interference
by executives and producers and all
these different people that have their
own bodies unmediated yes unmediated is
giant yeah yeah well that's all part of
the reason you're so popular too is like
you just put this on like so you've got
exactly the right balance of competent
production because there's nothing
excess about it like it's competent but
no more than that I know that's by
design but you also don't edit it it's
like what you see is what you get it's
like everyone's relieved by that we can
make our own damn decisions no I think
that's very important if you're gonna
have a conversation with someone that's
honest you you can't decide what to
leave in and what to take out and it's
just well that's partly also why I deal
with the press the way I do yeah if I'm
gonna have a full conversation it's like
I'm willing to take the hits yeah and
and I understand what you're saying but
that's one of the reasons why it
frustrates me so much is that I see what
they're doing and I'm like what you're
doing is ancient what you're doing is
it's it's this is what people did twenty
years ago thirty years ago for you can't
really do that anymore
you can't misrepresent people you used
to be able to if you were in the press
you could take people quote amount of
context do whatever the [ __ ] you wanted
put an article about them they couldn't
do a goddamn thing about it it happened
to me in nineteen
it was like ninety-nine
I did a I had a comedy CD that came out
and this woman wrote an article about it
and it just she just lied she lied about
my perspective she lied about the bits
she misquoted the bits she didn't just
paraphrase them
she changed what the bits were to make
them you know misogynist or hateful or
whatever it was and in doing so I that
there was no recourse there was nothing
that I could do about them like wow I'd
never experienced that before I was like
this is stunning and then I found out
this person did that a lot and this is
what she did and there's ultimate power
that comes at being the person who has
the pen being the person who has the
typewriter and you you're the person who
works for you know the Boston Globe or
whatever the publication is that that is
something that existed forever you know
and that you had to be either a friend
of the press you had to play ball you
had you had a bend to their will you to
do what they wanted you to do and they
could misrepresent you and choose to
paint you in any way they like and it's
one of the reasons why I don't do
anything anymore
I don't do any interviews anymore I
don't do anything I don't want to do
anything yeah this I do enough man you
want to know about me it [ __ ] there's
a thousand podcasts there's more than a
thousand there's I think there's there's
1,100 and there's a bunch of other ones
three right let's just it doesn't make
any sense
yeah well that that's that that it may
also be the position that I increasingly
find myself in I think it's the right
position because then the
misrepresentations don't exist anymore
so then the only problem is the dispute
over the actual ideological
conversations or the other the actual
concept but you know the thing is you
know you made a point there that's quite
interesting it's like we are in a new
media landscape so now if someone comes
out as a as a media figure with some
institutional credibility and
misrepresents its exposed and so then
the question is how much risk should use
shoulder to expose the proclivity for
media misrepresentation and the answer
to that might be some now it might be
moving you know maybe I've done enough
of that I mean it would be easier for me
in many ways if I just stopped doing it
but but there's some utility and having
it play out and so
well so I'm trying to get I'm trying to
only take those opportunities that
appear to have more benefit than risk
and when I defining benefit
well the question is then what
constitutes benefit and I guess what
constitutes benefit is well that would
further the attempts that I'm making to
bring information to a vast number of
people that could conceivably help them
stabilize and improve their individual
lives that's worth a certain amount of
risk
well it certainly increases your profile
increases your profile and even if you
know you have 60% of these people are
gonna get a bad perception of you 40% of
these people that never heard of you now
we're going to understand who you are
because they do further investigation
yeah so there's some benefit in that but
the negative I mean I get text messages
from random people that I was friends
with years ago let's say this Jordan
Peterson is just such a lying sack of
[ __ ] and he's this not only I don't even
know who the [ __ ] you are and then
second of all like why are you
contacting me you know I'm saying hi
you're saying he's a scam artist he's a
fraud he's in it and I'm like wow and so
they'll see an interview you know like
the the Jim Jefferies clip which is a
minute long or whatever it is or the
Vice piece or the the initial Kathy
Newman piece and they just form this
determined position on you and then Reid
hit pieces on you and then this is where
they take their opinion this is where
it's from it's and it's like these are
the last gasps of a dying medium I
really do I just I think too I don't I
don't think that people appreciate it I
think the people that are listening to
this that do appreciate long-form
conversations and with all warts and all
all the ugliness and the mistakes and
the critical errors and the the people
that appreciate that they they they have
a real hate for being lied to you know
because it's it it changed when when you
try never being treated as if they're
stupid yes
yeah which they aren't yeah that's both
it's just it's it's deceptive when you
when you added someone and take their
words
to context and change them around you're
being deceptive the New York Times did
that again this week they had some
philosophy professor from Hong Kong
University write a piece on me and he
took they quoted me it was a sentence
there's like the first phrase was in
quotes and then there was some joining
words and then the second phrase was in
quotes and there was some joining words
and then the third phrase was in quotes
and the three quotes added up to a
statement that bore no resemblance
whatsoever to what I was saying how can
they do that in the New York Times that
seems to me to be something that should
be the the I don't but they still I
don't think they can do I think they're
killing their brand so fast that they
can't but it is so disturbing to me as a
person who's been a fan of the New York
Times forever I just don't understand
how they could allow that to happen how
could you allow your what what is the
gold standard for journalism how could
you allow it to become something that
willfully misrepresents someone they
never did to push an idea I never did
put my book on the New York Times
bestseller list it's quite comical how's
that possible oh they have rules which
they don't disclose but one of them
apparently is well if the book is
published and counted and distributed in
the United States then it doesn't count
even though they've had books like that
on the New York Times bestseller list
before and I think okay well is this bad
or good it's like well it's bad because
to the degree that I might want to be on
the New York Times bestseller list
although I haven't been losing any sleep
over but you're selling I know how many
books are selling yeah it's basically
being the best-selling book in the world
since January you know it's gone up and
down to some degree but right it should
be the number one New York Times
bestseller so they they they have the
reasons and but I look at that and I
think oh well you can only do that ten
times until you're done like because
it's a fatal error
you have the gold standard for
measurement you're not measuring
properly you're burning up your brand
you think well we're the New York Times
so we can burn up our brand it's like no
you can't Newsweek is gone Time magazine
is a shallow is a shell of its former
self like the big things disappear and
they disappear when they get crooked and
ideologically rigid and so that's what's
happening at the New York Times not with
everyone there but with plenty of them
and they'll die faster than people think
but it's so confusing to me that
it didn't used to be that yeah and now
it is and are they just responding to
this new world where you have to have
clickbait journalism and you know some
people are struggling to find people to
actually buy physical newspapers which
is well it's a different thing it's hard
to say like because maybe see it's weird
because you don't have to resort to
clickbait because these long-form
discussions are the antithesis of
clickbait right are they struggling in
terms of like how many people buy them
safer oh absolutely every newspaper the
newspapers in Canada went cap and hand
to the federal government for subsidies
about six months ago because they're
dying so fast and so some of it is
they're being supplanted by technology
that's a huge part of it but as they are
supplanted they get more desperate they
publish more polarizing stories that
works in the short term to garner more
views but it alienates people from the
brand and speeds their demise classic
death spiral of a big of a big
organization and that's going to clean
things out like mad I mean I don't know
where CNN is in the Cable News rankings
now our cable show rankings but it keeps
falling but it's falling in the rankings
as cable itself disintegrates and dies
why do you need cable TV right
no one needs cable TV the only people
who have cable TV are the people who
haven't figured out yet that you can
replace it entirely online for like 1/10
the price with with much less hassle but
the art is people want a location they
can go to to find out what's going on in
the world and this is the one thing that
they used to represent and you know I
mean I don't think Fox News is any
better I think you just have these
ideological extremes left and right and
I remember very clearly watching the
election coverage before the election
like we were leading up to the election
I would go Fox News and then I go CNN I
just would go back and forth with them
on my cable yeah and I would just be
laughing I'm like what is really
happening in the world because I'm
getting to different stories I'm getting
Russia and I'm getting Hillary's emails
this is I don't know what the [ __ ] is
what what is happening I'm getting [ __ ]
grabbing and I'm getting you know
Benghazi yeah you know I'm this is what
I'm getting and I don't understand like
why this is obviously ideological this
is well not just look it might be that
as the technology is supplanted
the ideological polarization increases
as the thing dies right there struggling
for anyone to pay attention and this is
the way they have to do it to any shore
and I think what's happening on the
other side which is the side you occupy
say is that a new technology that's long
form that deals with many of those
problems is emerging and it's going to
emerge it's going to be victorious
but in the me might already be
victorious in the meantime little baby
stuff still exists in the digital world
yeah you know and then you're getting a
lot of the articles that are written
about you people are absorbing these
articles not from a physical form you're
getting it from from digital yeah well
okay so then the sense is well do you
have fundamental trust in the judgment
of your fellow man let's say and my
answer to that is yes because although
I've been pilloried to a great degree by
the radical types in the commentariat
and in that classic journalists though
comments with regards to me on YouTube
are 50 to 1 in my favor and and that's
even the case when the ideologues put up
videos about me they're designed to
discredit me and I've sold a million and
a half books it's going to be published
in 40 countries and thousands of people
are coming to my lectures and so I would
say the attempts to discredit me aren't
working so and now I think that's
because that even like even if you go to
youtube you can see Jordan Peterson
smashes leftist journalists you know as
a clickbait thing someone's taken a
two-minute clip from a video and they
put it out and they're using that
clickbait headlines to attract attention
it's like it does attract attention and
that probably even furthers polarization
but I think that most people enough
people that's the prayer enough people
are going for the long form thorough
discussion so that the sensible will
will triumph that's what I'm hoping for
the sensible will triumph no I agree and
I think that is what's happened yeah I
think that's why this fifty to one
number exists is that there but the the
number one in that 50 the 50 verses you
know the 50 people that are actually
understanding what's going on and
agreeing with you versus the number one
that are trying to willfully
misrepresent you they still exist and
they're loud you know they're and
they're
to be right and this is one of the
things that people love to do they love
to fight to be right instead of
examining their position and wondering
whether or not they are taking you out
of context and misrepresenting your
positions to the world willfully and
doing so in order to paint a negative
picture of you that does not accurately
represent who you are what you stand for
yes but by doing this virtue without any
of the work they're also destroying
their own credits this is what's
devastating it's like the in they're
trying to win they're killing themselves
right well and that's a good that's a
good motif for the entire conversation
it's like try hard to hard to win you
kill yourself you were talking last
night when we were when we were over
dinner you said that one of the most
deadly things for a fighter to do is to
overestimate his own position you're
gonna get your abilities yes if you
overestimate your abilities you you're
you're in deep deep trouble because
you're gonna get a wake-up call right
and objectivity is one of the most
critical aspects of development you have
to be you have to be objectively
assessing your strengths and weaknesses
at every step of the way that's brava
bravado right I'm I'm trying to prove
how I'm so powerful I'm so powerful it's
an ego shield and that's why I was
saying that the ego is the enemy were
talking about right so I get you know I
want to get into this because this is a
I think this is a fascinating thing with
you personally that your diet you're on
this carnivore dog yeah no okay so I
want to preface that with something I am
NOT a dietary expert so I'm not speaking
as an uninformed citizen yes well this
is anecdotal evidence from a human being
it is dealt with autoimmune issues yes
their whole life yes you have done this
for how long now I've been on a pure
carnivore diet for about two months and
a pretty very very low carb greens only
modified carnivore diet for about a year
so in the year and-and-and-and a
low-carb diet for two years so from the
time that I've known you I've known you
for what two and a half years now
sometimes yeah yeah when I first met you
you had much more weight on your body
yeah you look different yeah and you
were back then you were eating like the
standard diet right like normal people
yes pasta
bread yeah chicken whatever yes right
you shifted over to only meat and greens
I saw you and like you look fantastic
I'm like what are you doing
you're like I changed my diet I only
meat in green so I was like wow that's
fascinating well I felt like okay what
you're doing is cutting out refined
sugars and all these different things
that are problematic preservatives all
the [ __ ] processed foods and you're
having this extreme health benefit I was
like wow that's really excellent you're
showing great discipline then you
decided to take it to another place and
cut out the greens you know what was the
motivation for cutting out the greens
well all of the motivation for this has
been my experience with my daughter
because she has an unbelievably serious
autoimmune disease I just talked to her
this what is it called
well it's rich arthritis but it there's
there's way more to it than that
but the arthritis was the major set of
symptoms she had 40 affected joints and
she had to have her hip replaced and her
ankle replaced when she was 15 and 16
and so she basically hobbled around on
two broken legs for two years in extreme
agony and that was just a tiny fraction
of the whole set of problems I just
talked to her this morning she's in
Chicago looks like she has to have her
ankle replacement replaced so that's
next on the horizon but but apart from
that she is doing so well now it is
absolutely beyond comprehension so she's
she's she's very trim she had a baby but
she's very trimmed she's down to about
118 pounds she's about five foot six
she's just glowing with health all of
her autoimmune system symptoms are gone
all of them and she was also seriously
depressed like severely depressed way
worse than you think she couldn't stay
awake for more than about six hours
without taking Ritalin
and she was dying and hide a cousin my
cousin's daughter she died when she was
thirty from an associated autoimmune
condition so there's a fair bit of this
in our family it was bloody bleak I'll
tell you and my wife always had a
suspicion that this was dietary related
you know and well we did notice that
when Michaela was young if she ate
oranges or strawberries that she'd get a
rash like there were there were there
and then when she developed arthritis if
she ate oranges in particular that would
definitely cause a flare it was the only
thing we could see
the problem is is that in order to
identify a dietary component the
response has to be pretty quick after
you eat the thing like if it's two days
later how the hell are you gonna figure
that out a lot of these responses appear
to be delayed for four days and last a
month so good luck figuring that out
anyways Mikayla noticed about three
years ago no more than that now five
years ago she was at Concordia
University and struggling with her with
her illness and and all the Association
associated problems she noticed that
around exam time she was starting to
develop real skin problems and my
cousin's daughter who I mentioned had
really bad skin problems and wounds that
wouldn't heal and that was partly part
of the process that eventually killed
her and she thought oh it must be stress
and then she thought wait a second I
really changed my diet when I'm studying
all I do is eat bagels all I do is eat
bread sandwiches she thought maybe it's
the bread so she cut out gluten first
and it had a remarkable effect like a
really remarkable effect and then she
went on a radical elimination diet all
the way down to nothing but chicken and
broccoli and then her symptoms started
to drop off one by one like and and like
one of the things that happened is she
started to wake up in the morning she
started to be able to stay awake all day
when you're only staying awake for six
hours with riddlin staying awake all day
that's like having a life and so a whole
bunch of things improved then her
depression went away and I've had
depression since I was 13 probably and
very severe and I've treated at a
variety of ways some of them quite
successfully but it's been a constant
battle and my father had it and his
father had it and it's all just rife in
my family and my wife has autoimmune
problems and her niece a depression
define it oh oh would you define it
because that's a word that's a blanket
term yeah
well imagine imagine that you wake up
and that you remember that all your
family was killed in a horrible accident
yesterday you would feel that even
though the times wrong yes yes
just-just-just worse than that because
well one of the things Mikayla told me
was she thought well what's it like to
be depressed
imagine you have a dog and you really
loved the dog and then the dog dies and
then about three years ago our dog died
and that was Mikayla's dog and she
really liked that dog and she said that
was bad but it's nowhere near as bad as
being depressed
and I asked her to at one point when she
was about 15 or 16 I said look you've
got a choice kid here's the choice you
can either have depression or arthritis
which one I'll take the arthritis
after she'd lost two joints so it was no
joke it's no joke man it there isn't any
no I wouldn't say that I wouldn't say
there's nothing worse because worse is a
very deep hole right but it's bad yeah
people prove you wrong right oh yes
definitely worse worse is a deep hole
anyways her depression went away all
these symptoms went away and like
radically so what changed her from
chicken and broccoli to carnivore well
she she kept experimenting and she got
very sensitive to all sorts of foods in
the aftermath of that too so this is why
I wouldn't recommend that anybody does
this casually because we don't
understand much about it but the upshot
was that well she kept she kept she kept
experimenting and she started to add
things back and take them away and
sometimes when she added things the
results were devastating she was like
done for a month she eats the wrong
thing done for a month all the symptoms
came back the depression came back she
thought that her whole dietary theory
was wrong because it lasted so long it
was so extreme and it's like I took her
two years to figure out that really what
she could eat was beef and greens and
then she figured out that she could only
eat beef so greens themselves well look
so what happened okay so two years ago
she said dad you have tried this diet
because you have a lot of the same
symptoms as me now I didn't have
arthritis but I had a lot of the other
symptoms and I thought oh Christ
okay Mikayla I can try anything for a
month she said try it for a month I
thought okay whatever I can hang by my
fingernails from the windowsill for a
month it's like it's just not that big a
deal
and so I eliminated I went on really low
carb diet okay so this is what happened
I had gastric reflux disorder and I was
snoring quite a lot I stopped snoring
the first week I thought what the hell
that's supposed to be associated with
weight loss because I had gained some
weight I weighed about 212 pounds and
I'm I what six one and a half so that
was my maximum weight I stopped snoring
which was a great relief to tear me so
that just quit and that's a big deal
right because if you snore you have
sleep apnea and then you don't sleep
right it's like not a good thing okay
next I started waking up in the mornings
I'd never been able to wake up in the
mornings my whole life I always had to
stumble to the shower and then maybe I
could wake up took me an hour and I felt
terrible and so
all the sudden I woke up it was like oh
look at that I'm awake in the morning
and I'm clear-headed and things aren't
gloomy and horrible it's like well he's
not weird then I lost seven pounds the
first month I thought seven pounds
that's a lot in a month and I'd already
gone for a whole year on a sugar-free
diet I didn't lose any weight and I'd be
the exercise a sugar free but did you
cut out bread no no it was just no
desserts no sugar no and I thought that
might do it didn't make any difference
at all seven pounds well then then I
lost seven pounds the next month then I
lost seven pounds the next month I lost
seven pounds every month for seven
months like I'd throw away all my
clothes I went back to the same weight
that I was when I was 26 and my
psoriasis disappeared and I had floaters
in my right eye and they cleared up and
then the last thing that went away from
me I was still having a [ __ ] of a time
with mood regulation and that sucked
because when I changed my diet I didn't
respond to antidepressants properly
anymore they weren't working and so
although I was getting better physically
on a variety of ways like radical ways I
was really having a [ __ ] of a time
regulating my mood and I was having
sporadic really negative reactions to
food when I ate something I shouldn't so
that took about a year and half to clear
up and I was still really anxious in the
morning up to three months ago like
horribly and then it would get better
all day people said well you're under a
lot of stress and I thought yeah yeah
I've been under a lot of stress for like
ten years it's like it's a lot but it
wasn't any more stressful than helping
my daughter deal with her illness that's
for sure that no this is something
different and she said to me quit eating
greens and I thought oh really
Jesus Mikayla I'm eating cucumbers
lettuce broccoli and chicken and beef
it's like I have to cut out the goddamn
greens it's like try it for a month okay
within a week I was 25% less anxious in
the morning within two weeks 75% and
I've been better every single day I'm
better now probably than I've ever been
in my life and I haven't been taking
antidepressants for a whole year so I
don't know what and I weigh 162 pounds
like I have no I'm and I've actually
gained musculature I've been doing some
working out but not a lot and so I can
sleep six hours a night no problem I
wake up the morning I'm awake if I take
a 15 minute nap that used to take me an
hour to recover for
that's gone here's the coolest thing
I've had gum disease since I was 25
that's been serious enough to have I've
had to have minor surgical interventions
scraping and that sort of thing to keep
it at bay
it's go on I checked with my dentist
before this last tour no inflammation
and that's associated with heart disease
by the way gum inflammation and
gingivitis it's a good risk factor heart
disease it means the systemic
inflammation is gone and it's not
supposed to happen you're not supposed
to recover from gingivitis and my gums
are in perfect shape it's like what the
hell so here's what happened I lost 50
pounds it's like that's a lot right I'm
nowhere near as hungry as I used to be
my appetites probably formed by 70% I
don't get blood sugar dysregulation
problems I need way less sleep I get up
in the morning and I'm fine I'm not
anxious I'm not depressed I don't have
psoriasis my legs were numb on the sides
that's gone I'm certainly intellectually
at my best at the moment which is a
great relief especially doing this tour
depression is gone
I'm stronger I can swim better and my
gum disease is gone it's like what the
hell and you've done you've done no
blood work so you don't know what your
lipid lipid profile is or no I'll get
that done again when I go back take any
vitamins no no I eat beef and salt and
water that's it and I never cheat ever
not even a little bit no not soda no
wine I drink club soda well that's still
water well you know when you're down to
that level no it's not Joe there's
there's club soda Joe's really bubbly
there's Perrier which is sort of bubbly
there's flat water and there's hot water
so that's crazy well we ate last night
and I ate what you ate just we both had
that giant tomahawk yeah I had wine
though yeah
I'm curious about this I'm very curious
and I think you might try it but I eat a
lot of vegetables yeah but I don't have
any problems like health problems hey
man like I'm not
disclaimer number two I am not
recommending this to anyone however I
have had however I have had many many
people come up to me on the tour and say
look I've been following your daughter's
blog and I've lost like a hundred pounds
I think what you lost a hundred pounds
see I lost 100 pounds in six months I
talked to a woman yesterday she lost 15
pounds in one month she was 70 it's like
this is all right here's a question
why is everyone fat and stupid that's a
question man because it's new is there
something else it is it's new and it's
not a sedentary lifestyle that that
hypothesis doesn't seem to hold water
there's something wrong with the way
we're eating and the what's wrong is
that we're eating way too many
carbohydrates I think but they're never
on a no x8 shift the elimination of most
carbohydrates has made a big shift in my
life and I do cheat occasionally with
bread and occasionally with pasta I will
I will go off with ice cream and things
along those lines but most of the time
I'm just eating meat and vegetables most
of the time and then I have a cheat day
like you know once a week like yeah
especially if I go to dinner I'll have a
little pasta and it doesn't seem to mess
too bad but I do feel shitty after I do
it it's like for simple mouth pleasure
I'm allowing myself to feel tired after
we're tired yeah that's a big one man
yeah but like I out yeah like well
really I can't no and it's so
interesting to like I can't believe I
can wake up in the morning okay that's
never happened to me in my whole life
and when I was a kid 13 12 I had a [ __ ]
of a time waking up in the morning it
was just brutal I just thought that's
how it was this is what I mean again I'm
not a nutritionist either but what's
fascinating to me is I haven't heard any
negative stories about people doing this
well I have a negative story okay okay
one of the things that both Mikayla and
I noticed was that when we restricted
our diet and then ate something we
weren't supposed to the reaction to
eating what we weren't supposed to was
absolutely catastrophic but it show what
did you switch to what did you eat
rather um well the worst response I
think we're allergic to or allergic
whatever the hell this is having an
inflammatory response to something
called sulfites and we had some apple
cider that had sulfites in it and that
was really not good like I was done for
a month that was the first time I talked
to Sam Harris you were done for a month
oh yeah it took me out for a month it
was awful real yeah yeah so I would sell
oh and what so this is right before this
whole truth conversation with Sam Harris
at the Guthrie in the mud during during
it was I think the day I talked to Sam
was like the worst day of my life not
because of talking to Sam but it was
just physical Jesus I was so dead but I
didn't want to not do it
cider like what was his own fights in
what was it doing there oh it produced
an overwhelming sense of impending doom
and I seriously been overwhelming like
there's no way I could have lived like
that if that would have lasted for see
Mikayla knew by that point that it would
probably only last a month and I was
like a month yeah my [ __ ] cider well
I didn't sleep that that month I didn't
sleep for 25 days I didn't sleep at all
I didn't sleep at all for 25 days how is
it possible that I'll tell you how it's
possible you lay in bed frozen in
something approximating terror for eight
hours and then you get up oh my god oh
yeah no and this is some [ __ ] cider
from
that's what we thought yeah I mean look
again I don't know what the hell I'm
talking about okay this is all a mystery
to me
the fact that my daughter was so sick
see the one thing that I did know cuz I
scoured the literature on arthritis when
she was a kid the scientific literature
and because we were interested in the
dietary connection and the only thing I
could find that was reliable was that if
people with arthritis fasted their
symptoms reliably went away and that's
actually a well-documented finding but
then if they started to eat again then
there were symptoms came back and I
thought well what the hell does it not
matter what they eat they can't be
reactive to everything it's like no but
they can be reactive to almost
everything and the difference between
everything and almost everything that's
a big difference
and so Mikayla seems to be maybe me too
and hammies on the same diet because she
has autoimmune problems on her side of
the family so Mikayla seemed to inherit
all of them your skin looks better old
Jesus Joe I'm waiting whatever here yeah
yeah you you you look like more vibrant
it's very strange thank you thank you
welcome
but the see my point is I you're saying
that there's a there is problems with
this diet but that doesn't seem to be a
problem with a diet seems a problem with
deviating from the diet your body
becomes a custom with well one of the
thighs Isis that we've been pursuing and
there's some justification for this and
the scientific literature is that the
reason that you lay on layers of fat is
because the fat acts as a buffer between
you and the toxic things that you're
eating because fat is actually an organ
it has functions other than merely the
storage of of calories and maybe when
you strip out that protective layer then
you're more sensitive to what you
shouldn't be eating this is all
speculative hypotheses right or maybe
you sensitize yourself by removing it
from your constant diet I don't bloody
well know well I would think it would be
much more likely that because you think
about people who are alcoholics they
develop a tolerance to alcohol
you know you get off of that and then
you have a drink and your tolerances are
shot and then you immediately have a
reverse reaction to the alcohol yeah
same thing with marijuana yeah when
people do it all the time you your body
becomes tolerant well I think I think
that the layering of fat on might be
part of the tolerance mechanism hmm so
it's not merely a matter of
caloric intake it's a matter of of toxic
telluric intake buffered by whatever it
is that fat is doing as a neuro
endocrine organ but again like I said I
said I'm out of my depth here but you
know the whole everyone's out of their
depth the goddamn food pyramid was made
by the Department of Agriculture not the
Department of Health it wasn't
predicated on any scientific studies
whatsoever
we should have we shouldn't be eating
massive quantities of corn syrup we we
way too many carbohydrates Michaela
posted a paper the other day a doctor
has successfully treated type 1 diabetes
with a carnivore diet type 1 not type 2
so that's bloody impressive yeah it's
it's very curious to me because you're
talking about the one adverse reaction
which is when you deviated from the diet
yeah what I'm talking about is when I
read people's accounts of trying this
diet it's almost universally positive
you know but again that's probably and
it's the same with all these stories
that I'm collecting as I'm touring and
you know people lots of people have come
up to me and said look I lost 45 pounds
in the last three months I think yeah I
think what's shocking to me I think well
what do you make of that say well I
can't believe it well who can oh I
couldn't believe it
fifty pounds it's like first of all I
didn't know I had fifty pounds to lose
you know I thought it was maybe 20
pounds heavier than I should have been
there should have been 185 something
like that I guess that's 25 to 30 pounds
that was the maximum thought no no I
lost I meant 162 and I was at 212 so
what's that fifty fifty pounds it's a
lot of weight Jesus I threw had to throw
all my clothes away
it's I can't believe it when I saw you
last night I was like you're so slim
like your your stomach is completely
flat and it's and this is not a lean
mean fighting yeah man and you're not a
an exercise fanatic it's not like you're
starving yourself it's not like you know
and I'm not running 5 that's another
thing I should say to people if you want
to try a diet like this you eat enough
meat and fat so you were not hungry okay
you can't get hungry
you're not eating enough if you're
hungry and if you're hungry you're gonna
cheat and it's gonna drive you stark
raving mad the other thing that was
really cool is like I really liked
sweets like I've kind of lived on peanut
butter sandwiches and chocolate milk
not really but that was my go-to food
you know both of which were terrible for
me but after I stopped eating
carbohydrates for a month the
carbohydrate cravings went away you know
last night when we were out for dinner
somebody ordered bread pudding and I
bloody love bread pudding with caramel
and and and ice cream so it was sitting
there and I could smell it like you know
I thought I could go all fantastic mr.
Fox on that bread pudding and just tear
it down in about 15 seconds but it
wasn't it wasn't as intense as a craving
for a cigarette if you're Nick's
ex-smoker it was like God be really nice
to eat that but like my appetite
declined by about 75% that's been
permanent that's been so there's a
perverse thing for you
I eat way less and now I'm not as hungry
okay how does that make sense
well you're not eating way less you're
eating way less thing yes you have 30
ounce steak last night yes yes I'm doing
my best not to be hungry although it
didn't look like I was 30 no no no
there's a small 30 on the steak well I
think it starts out 30 ounces before
they cook it right loses a considerable
right right very fatty right but that's
the other thing too you you must have to
get a lot of fat yeah well I eat fatty
cuts of steak and yeah Michaela is
buying fat directly from the butcher
store and we cooked that up cut it into
small pieces and fry it up till it's
crispy Wow it's actually quite delicious
it's not bread pudding with ice cream
but it's not funny
you mean Dino it's so ridiculous well I
wanna I want your blood profile I want
to find out what's going on with you
because one of the big misconceptions
when it comes to cholesterol and
saturated fat and food is that if you
eat dietary cholesterol that it affects
your
blood cholesterol levels it's not it's a
super common misconception well those so
the thing about clinical studies with
diet are virtually impossible to conduct
because you just can't you can't conduct
a proper randomly distributed controlled
experiment it's too hard so a lot of
what we're trying to do is pull out
information from correlations right you
can't do it which is one of the real
problems with correlating meat with
cancer and diabetes and all these
different diseases is because people are
eating a bunch of [ __ ] with that oh yeah
and they have different lifestyle
profiles or like there's just endless
numbers of confounding variables you
only need one con founding variable
that's that's relevant to screw up the
study right you can't get that
information with correlational studies
we try because it's impossible to do the
studies but how many people are
incredulous when they're honey people
wouldn't when they're hearing about this
Oh everybody everybody well you or not
but you know you're interested in this
sort of thing but they should be
incredulous like when people make absurd
claims is like oh well I had 50 health
problems and I stopped eating everything
but meat and they went away it's like
whoo sure it's like yeah well wasn't you
dying so yeah and I see the results and
I know it's an anecdote I bloody well
understand that and I'm highly skeptical
about all of this but I'm telling you so
that's why I'm telling you what happened
to me and what happened to my daughter
and also what happened to my wife
because she's Tammy was always in good
shape and she's exercised a lot and she
reduced to the to the pure carnivore
died about a month ago she lost like 12
pounds
she was already slim she's back to the
same weight she was when she was 21
she's like 58 you know and she doesn't
look 58 I can tell you that so it's
really fascinating it's really
fascinating because I just I as a person
who studied diet for many years I would
assume that you need phytonutrients I
would assume do you need vitamins
supplements like vitamin C for example
turns out if you don't eat carbohydrates
you don't need vitamin C ha who woulda
guessed how does that work I don't I
don't remember Michaela outlined a paper
for me
vitamin C is necessary for carbohydrate
metabolism but if you don't if again
remember everyone listening I am NOT an
expert in this field right so
but but I want you to get your blood
tested because I think if be pretty
funny if it was in good shape yeah it
would be I mean I'd like to find out
what your nutrient levels are and where
they're coming yeah I mean what what I'm
getting a little cramping in my toes
from time to time so I'm not sure about
potassium possibility that's a
supplement it's very easy which is why
I'm concerned but like and also minerals
you know you know in certain minerals
you're getting from vegetables that
you're probably not getting yeah well
this is all like look it seems not hard
to supplement that stuff though
colloidal minerals you know there's some
mineral pills you could take plenty of
well there are plants are people who
basically lived on meat you know the any
what did the mess I basically did yeah
there some supplementation but not a lot
yeah and apparently if you do a
carnivore diet you're supposed to eat
more organ meat and I do some of that
but not a lot but I can tell you like
I'm I mean well look I wouldn't be doing
this if it wasn't producing positive
results yeah it's not like it's fun
running for a while well it makes you a
social pariah mm-hm like let's invite
the Petersons over oh yeah they don't
eat anything oh we have other friends
that's like well that's how it works
it's not malevolence right it's just if
you're a pain no one invites you out so
so I'm a social pain and an ideological
pain and now I'm a nutritional pain
because there's no friends how difficult
is it when you're trying to get
breakfast like what do you do when you
oh well lots of times when we were
traveling we cook so we'll usually stay
in places where you can cook oh okay but
most places you can get a steak mm-hmm
and so that's mostly what we do I've
been traveling in a Motorhome and so
we've been cooking in the Motorhome
and so not carry beef jerky with me
which we make what so yeah it's crazy
you make your own beef jerky well it's
like we have a dehydrator and you just
basically put salt on and throw in the
dehydrator so that works pretty well you
anticipate continuing this well forever
Cod forevers a long time I'd like to be
able to eat more things but I'm gonna
experiment with that very very very very
very cautiously I'm gonna add mushrooms
next because maybe I could eat them well
this is why I'm asking there
positive benefits that a lot of people
achieve and and experience when they
switch to a vegan diet yeah one of the
things it is is you get off of the
standard American diet with lots of
refined sugars and a lot of
preservatives a little [ __ ] and then you
find positive benefits Chris Kresser has
gone into depth about this but then over
time the nutritional bent deficiencies
in that start to wear on your health yep
and I'm wondering well it's certainly
possible well certainly eventually this
diet will kill me no life will well
you're right
biology will yes unless so it science
intervened
might be that for some people of Megan
dieters or vegan diet is preferable to a
standard American diet well for sure to
a standard American diet but also
there's so much biological variability
yeah you know the things that bothers
some people don't bother other people at
all and that's that's something that we
got to take into consideration yeah well
that's why I don't want to universalize
from my experience you know but but this
is what's happened to me and this is
what's happened to my wife and my
daughter
so and all of its being well with
Michaela it's it's miraculous I cannot
believe it the last time I saw it made
me cry I've never seen her look like
that she looks so good she's so healthy
and all her other joints are not
experiencing any problem and she's
taking no immunomodulators at all
no medication none and she was on him
fro Jesus yes more medication than you
can shake a stick at methotrexate which
is basically they use it to treat cancer
it's a it's a what's what's the cancer
treating drugs called whatever I don't
remember at the moment she was on Enbrel
which really really helped but but later
opened to bacterial infections so she
always had pneumonia in the fall but
envel really helped and then heavy doses
of antidepressants and Ritalin and Jesus
how long has she been on this carnivore
diet oh god she's only been eating meat
it's got to be at least six to eight
months now Wow and does she get blood
work done uh yep and her blood work I
won't comment on that I don't know the
details of her blood work
I don't know to answer that hmm it's
fascinating I'm curious I'm considering
trying it for a while the problem is I
eat so much game meat you know what
there's a lot get some fat yeah that's
the trick there try it for a month see
what happens you what the hell a month
you know just a month ya know a months
not hard yeah interesting
all right let's wrap this up all right
three hours it's re 2:20 believe it or
not hey crazy prison it's always a
pleasure great see one thing I want to
bring up ya for it how weird is this
whole association to you cuz it's weird
to me the IDW yeah oh I D WI yeah
of course it's election darkweb it is
it's like I've been trying to puzzle it
out I mean I think what it is is a loose
collection of early adopters of a
revolutionary technology that's what it
looks like to me and and it we found
each other because we're all doing the
same thing but it's also a bunch of
people that are honest intellectually
honest about their and and maybe don't
even disagree even agree on folio
definitely but honest about perceptions
well and also I think interested in
long-form discussion yeah right and and
able to engage in it because otherwise
we wouldn't be having the relative
success that we're having in the in the
in the milieu you know and it got a name
and that's kind of interesting and
that's Eric though yeah that's right
that's Eric yes he loves it most
interesting about I love to rib him yeah
well it's got this funny conspiratorial
element there that's sort of true and
sort of mostly dramatic and was a
mathematician he's always looking for
patterns codes yeah yeah I don't know
what to make of it I mean things get a
name and then you think well why did
that get named and well someone named it
but yeah but the name stuck so it seemed
our proposed is some degree and well
what do we have in common most of us are
entrepreneurial most of us have our own
platform so we can speak independently
most of us are interested in long-form
philosophical discussions primarily not
political but but bordering on political
well just band's more political oh yes
he's the most yeah but he's also very
sophisticated political commentators so
he borders on both the philosophical and
the religious yes so
and then we're we're we're all the newly
new adopters of this new technology so
that's enough to put us in a group and
then well it turns out that we've all
been talking to each other but part of
the reason for that is while we're all
doing the same thing on the net so it's
not surprising that we're talking to
each other so I always go for the simple
explanations first you know it's not a
movement exactly what it is it's the
manifestation of a new technology and
then well do we have anything in common
that's worth discussing that would make
this a viable group let's say and the
answer to that is I don't know you know
I've been touring with Ruben that's been
good it's been good to have a comedian
along and he's also a good interviewer
he does the q and a's with me and it's
nice to have some levity in the mix
because of the conversations are the
discussions with the audience are very
serious although I can crack a joke and
I can't tell a joke but if something
funny occurs to be I can say it and
sometimes it's funny so that's something
you know and we've been we've been
discussing a fair bit and I had good
conversations with Shapiro and Harris
for that matter so there is lots of
interplay between us but I think that's
more because we we inhabit the same
technological space more than the same
ideological space apart from the fact
that we are actually interested in
dialogue fundamentally so we'll see I
mean I'm watching it with curiosity are
you apprehensive do you think this is
sure potential downsides so there's lots
of downsides to it sure there's lots of
downsides I mean first of all you know
most of us are on an individual
individualistic path I'm not come I'm
not really much of a group guy you know
so am I in this group it's like well I'm
pleased to be associated with you guys
that's for sure but I don't really know
what it would mean or if it should mean
anything or if it'll screw up what I'm
doing or if it I don't know anything
about it
but mostly I'm curious it's like huh
this is a group I thought this is the
Rat Pack I thought what I walked into
the restaurant of us because we were out
last night was Ben Shapiro Sam Harris
Eric Weinstein Dave Rubin Joe Rogan and
me right and my wife Tammy and so we're
all walking in there and I thought well
this is kind of like being
back in the 1950s I thought well I know
maybe it isn't but that's what came to
mind so I thought that's funny and it's
it's it's kind of cool and it's
interesting and it's edgy and all of
that but I'm not I'm not taking it
seriously
I'm not also not you know I'm not taking
it not seriously either
but I'm just watching I'm watching
everybody interact because it is a very
motley crew of people it is so and
they're very different and so but it was
very much joy thank you okay so why did
you think it was enjoyable it's good
conversation I mean yeah everyone that
was in that group has been on my podcast
or I've been on theirs and you know it's
a fun group of really honest interesting
people that you Lear very peculiar
people specially Eric yeah he's
listening right now I'm [ __ ] with him
I love that guy but no I mean they're
all it's there everyone's different but
everyone's also unique and they all
bring a lot to the table and that's
what's interesting about it you know
think the weird collection yeah you know
I I don't know what to think of it like
when Eric called me up about the whole
New York Times thing I'm like what are
you talking about right like why did you
do that
what I do what what did you be part of
the New York Times article I barely was
I just answered a couple questions but
there's a review you've got a picture
yeah they didn't direct they didn't
obsess they shouldn't taken a picture of
me I was dressed like I was going
onstage at the Comedy Store I didn't
wear anything any differently they were
trying to make a big deal of it I'm like
look I don't have any time this you want
to take a picture means is what I'm
wearing yeah and and we we did it on the
parking lot above the Comedy Store and
started to rain I go we're done I got to
go I got to go onstage I can't be
soaking wet you know and and then go
onstage and that was it
you know it was just okay so your take
on it is that it's well it's in turn is
its interest yes well this is the this
is probably another thing that unites
that group of people everyone in that
group of people is likely to get in
trouble because they find you too many
things interesting
right and it's trade openness that's
another thing that unites all of us yes
yeah and so and you know curiosity
killed the cat and so yeah but we're not
cats true curiosity also built the
pyramids it did it did it and it saved a
lot of caps too
let's end with that all right all right
Jordan all right pleasure my friend
chewy again see you always yeah yeah
that's it folks see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]